Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. On what foundation stands the warrior's pride? How just his hopes let Swedish Charles decide? A frame of adamant, a soul of fire, No dangers fright him, and no labors tire. Her love, her fear fear extends his wide domain, unconquered lord of pleasure and of pain. No joys to him Pacific sceptres yield, war sounds the trump.
感谢收听《一切皆历史》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、新系列的抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。战士的傲骨立于何种基石？任由瑞典的查理去断定他那正义的希望。金刚不坏的骨骼，烈火般的灵魂，没有危险能让他惊恐，没有劳苦能将他拖垮。她的爱，她的恐惧，拓宽了他的广袤疆域，他是欢愉与痛苦不可战胜的主宰。太平洋的权杖带给他不了任何欢乐，战争吹响了号角。
He rushes to the field. Behold surrounding kings, their power to combine and one capitulate and one resign. Peace courts his hand, but spreads her charms in vain. Think nothing gained, he cries, till naught remain. On Moscow's walls till Gothic standards fly and all will be mine beneath the polar sky. So that was Dr. Samuel Johnson, the greatest Englishman of all time in his poem, The Vanity of Human Wishes, which was published in 1749. And Swedish Charles,
他冲向战场。看吧，周围的君王联合他们的力量，一个投降，一个退位。和平向他伸出双手，却徒劳地散发着她的魅力。他大喊道：不留下一丝痕迹，就等于毫无收获。直到哥特式的军旗飘扬在莫斯科的城墙上，在极地的苍穹下，一切都将归我所有。这就是塞缪尔·约翰逊（Samuel Johnson）博士——这位有史以来最伟大的英国人在他 1749 年出版的诗作《人类欲望的虚妄》（The Vanity of Human Wishes）中的描写。而瑞典的查理，
the hero of that splendid passage, is not just the supreme antagonist of Peter the Great, a worthy rival to the theme of our ongoing series, but one of the most charismatic and extraordinary characters in all of European history. So he is the King of Sweden and he is a magnetic, terrifying, swashbuckling, obsessive oddball. Which is to say Dominic, that he is one of the great romantic heroes of history. And Dr. Johnson writes about him in due course, Byron will write about him as well. And he is a great theme of poetry right the way up to the present day. And this is the man who at the end of the last episode, Peter the Great has decided he will take on. That's right. So we're about to get into the Great Northern War, a 21 year war that completely reshapes the map of Europe. And as you said, Tom, we had two episodes last week about young Peter the Great. What an extraordinary character he is
作为那段精彩篇章中的英雄，不仅是彼得大帝的终极对头、与我们正在进行的系列节目主题势均力敌的对手，更是整个欧洲历史上最具个人魅力和非凡色彩的人物之一。他是瑞典国王，也是一个具有磁性、令人畏惧、耀眼夺目且执着的怪咖。也就是说，多米尼克，他是历史上伟大的浪漫主义英雄之一。约翰逊博士适时地写到了他，拜伦也将为他赋诗。直到今天，他依然是诗歌中盛久不衰的主题。而在上一集的结尾，彼得大帝已经决定要与这个人一较高下。没错。所以我们即将进入大北方战争，这是一场长达 21 年、彻底重塑欧洲版图的战争。正如你所说，汤姆，我们上周播出了两集关于年轻的彼得大帝的节目。他是一个多么非凡的人物啊，
with this enthusiasm for kind of inserting bellows into people, all the carry on with the Streltsy, these kind of murderous pikemen. It's a kind of, it's like a murderous stag do, isn't it? Yeah. His whole life. His whole life. But that is not Charles's vibe. You know, it really is. I don't want to go into the kind of Game of Thrones ice and fire cliche, but there is
热衷于把风箱塞进别人嘴里，还有斯特列利奇（Streltsy）那些令人眼花缭乱的破事，也就是那些凶残的长矛兵。这感觉就像是一场充满杀戮的单身派对，不是吗？是的。他的一生。他的一生。但这可不是查理的风格。你知道，我真的不想陷入那种《权力的游戏》冰与火的老套俗套中，但这里确实
a little element of that, isn't there? Because Charles the 12th, who I guess in the English speaking world is not as well known as he used to be, but certainly in the 18th and 19th century, he seemed an absolutely Titanic and a romantic hero. He is the perfect antagonist for Peter. He similarly enjoys a prank when he's a young man, but then he becomes this very icy sort of obsessive driven and brilliant military commander and the clash between these two men, their rivalry is going
有一点那种感觉，不是吗？因为十二世查理——我想他在英语世界里不如过去那么知名了，但在 18 世纪和 19 世纪，他绝对是一个泰坦式的人物和浪漫主义英雄。他是彼得的完美对头。他年轻时也喜欢恶作剧，但后来他变成了一个极其冷酷、执着、有驱动力且出色的军事指挥官。这两个人的冲突，他们的对抗将
to change the destinies, not just of Russia and Sweden, but of Poland, of Ukraine, of huge swathes of Northern and Eastern Europe. What's interesting also about him, you said that he's faded from probably the kind of the popular historical memory, but everybody knows about Hitler's invasion of Russia. Everyone knows about Napoleon's invasion of Russia. But Charles really is the prototype for this. He is the man who first reveals to Europe how difficult, effectively impossible it is to defeat this new superpower which is emerging on the Eastern flank of Europe. Absolutely. And his invasion of Russia is arguably the bizarrest of them all, because he just
改变的不仅是俄罗斯和瑞典的命运，还有波兰、乌克兰以及整个欧洲北部和东部大片地区的命运。关于他，还有一个有趣的地方——你刚才说他可能已经从大众的历史记忆中淡出了，但每个人都知道希特勒入侵俄罗斯，每个人都知道拿破仑入侵俄罗斯。然而查理才是这一切的原型。他是第一个向欧洲揭示在欧洲东翼崛起的新超级大国是多么难以击败——甚至是实际上不可能击败——的人。确实如此。而且他对俄罗斯的入侵可以说是所有人中最离奇的，因为他最后
ends up wandering hundreds of miles in the wrong direction. He ends up in the Ottoman Empire. It does indeed. Let's remind ourselves where we ended last week. We were in August 1700. Peter has been home, got home from his great embassy, his travels to England and the Dutch Republic and so on. He has signed a peace treaty with the Ottomans.
竟然在错误的方向上游荡了数百 miles。他最后甚至跑到了奥斯曼帝国。确实如此。让我们回想一下上周我们结束时的情景。当时是 1700 年 8 月。彼得刚刚回国，结束了他的宏伟使团之旅，即对英国和荷兰共和国等地的访问。他与奥斯曼人签署了一份和平条约。
News of that treaty reached Moscow on the 18th of August and then on the 19th the Kremlin issued a proclamation. The great Tsar has directed that for the many wrongs of the Swedish King and especially because of the Tsar's journey through Riga, you may remember that his gap year in Riga didn't start well. He was considered that Swedes had been very inhospitable. I like that degree of pettiness. Yeah. He suffered obstacles and unpleasantness at the hands of the people of Riga. His soldiers shall march in war on the Swedish towns. They say at the beginning they have two war aims, the provinces of Ingria and Karelia. That's the area around what is now St. Petersburg
该条约的消息于 8 月 18 日传到莫斯科，接着在 19 日，克里姆林宫发布了一份公告。伟大的沙长沙皇下令，由于瑞典国王犯下的诸多罪行，尤其是考虑到沙皇在里加的行程——大家可能还记得，他在里加的间隔年（gap year）开局并不顺利。人们认为瑞典人非常不好客。我喜欢这种程度的小肚鸡肠。是的。他在里加人民手中遭遇了阻碍和不愉快。他的军队将开赴战场，攻打瑞典城镇。他们说一开始他们有两个战争目标，即英格里亚（Ingria）和卡累利阿（Karelia）省。也就是现在圣彼得堡周边的地区，
and the area, the sort of the Finnish Russian borderlands. And Dominic, the key thing about that is that they, about the Baltic sea. They do indeed. So it would give Peter what he so desperately wants, a sea port that is not Archangel, that's on the Baltic coast. And the claim there is, Peter says these provinces have always historically belonged to Russia and we are just reclaiming what is rightfully ours.
以及芬兰与俄罗斯边界的那些土地。多米尼克，关键在于他们，关于波罗的海。确实如此。这将赋予彼得他梦寐以求的东西——一个不属于阿尔汉格尔斯克、位于波罗的海海岸的海港。其声称的理由是，彼得说这些省份历史上一直属于俄罗斯，我们只是在收回本属于我们的东西。
And actually Vladimir Putin invoked this very proclamation a few months after launching his war in Ukraine. He said, I'm doing exactly what Peter the Great did in 1700. I'm reclaiming what was taken from us and what is rightfully ours. Now, as this might suggest, the Swedes and the Russians are old enemies. So the Swedes have been fighting the cities of Novgorod and Moscow, the ancestors of Peter's realm since at least the 13th century. And in recent years, the Swedes have very much had the upper hand, so in what was called the time of troubles in the early 1600s, they
事实上，弗拉基米尔·普京在乌克兰战争爆发几个月后，就引用了这则公告。他说：我正在做彼得大帝在 1700 年所做的事。我正在收回被夺走且本属于我们的东西。正如这可能暗示的那样，瑞典人和俄罗斯人是老冤家。自至少 13 世纪以来，瑞典人就一直在与诺夫哥罗德和莫斯科的城市——彼得帝国的祖先——作战。近年来，瑞典人一直占据上风，所以在 1600 年代初期被称为“动乱时代”的时期里，他们
had bitten off a chunk of northern Russia. And for the whole of the 17th century, the Swedes have controlled Finland, they've controlled the Baltic coast of Estonia and Latvia and these two provinces, Ingria and Karelia. And that, as you say, Tom, basically means that Russia is, it sounds weird to say it, it's effectively landlocked because it only has one port, Archangel, and that port is frozen for half the year. So that's the only way that the trade to Holland and England, the two countries that Peter really cares about, can be carried on. So let's talk a little bit about Sweden. You know, I'm a great Scandi file.
咬下了俄罗斯北部的一大块领土。在整个 17 世纪，瑞典人一直控制着芬兰，控制着爱沙尼亚和拉脱维亚的波罗的海海岸，以及英格里亚和卡累利阿这两个省份。正如你所说，汤姆，这基本上意味着俄罗斯——这样说听起来可能有点奇怪——它实际上是一个内陆国，因为它只有一个港口阿尔汉格尔斯克，而这个港口一年中有半年是结冰的。所以，通往荷兰和英国这两个彼得真正关心的国家的贸易，只能通过这种唯一的方式进行。那么我们来聊聊瑞典吧。你知道，我对斯堪的纳维亚文化爱得深沉。
I love the Swedes. I like the joylessness of the Swedes. I like the kind of the grim, ruthless kind of, I like that aspect of their personality. The shard of ice. The shard of ice, exactly. So their empire, I mean, it sounds mad now to a lot of people, no doubt, to talk about the Swedish empire, but their empire is an amazing institution because Sweden is such a small country. It's going to get one and a half million people.
我喜欢瑞典人。我喜欢瑞典人那种毫无欢乐的特质。我喜欢那种阴郁、冷酷的风格，我喜欢他们性格中的那一面。冰晶。冰晶，没错。所以他们的帝国——对许多人来说，现在谈论瑞典帝国听起来肯定很疯狂——但他们的帝国是一个令人惊叹的体制，因为瑞典是一个如此小的国家。它当时只有一百五十万人口。
So what's Russia about this point? Eight million or something. The Swedes, they have this very agricultural population, farmers. They're spread across the vastness of the Swedish landscape. I mean, even today, Sweden is not densely populated at all. They have some natural resources. They have silver and copper and iron and those they export through Stockholm, which in the 17th century becomes one of the great ports of Northern Europe.
那么当时俄罗斯有多少人口？八百万左右吧。瑞典人拥有非常多的农业人口，也就是农民。他们散布在广袤的瑞典乡村中。我的意思是，即使在今天，瑞典的人口也一点都不稠密。他们拥有一些自然资源。他们拥有白银、铜和铁，并通过斯德哥尔摩将其出口。斯德哥尔摩在 17 世纪成为了北欧伟大的港口之一。
So for anyone who's been to Stockholm, to the old town. Gamla Stan. Gamla Stan. It's beautiful. It's amazing, isn't it? With the sort of orange buildings and the sort of copper roofs and the churches and all that. And so this is basically a 17th century creation. They get very rich from exporting all these things and they pour all that money into these military adventures. So most famously, Gustavus Adolphus in the Thirty Years War, which is a sort of forerunner, I think, of the Great Northern War in that when you look at the map, you're kind of, what are the Swedes doing in Bavaria or wherever
所以，对于任何去过斯德哥尔摩老城区的人来说。老城区（Gamla Stan）。老城区。太漂亮了，太棒了，不是吗？有那种橙色的建筑、铜制的屋顶、教堂等等。所以这基本上是 17 世纪的产物。他们通过出口所有这些物资变得非常富有，并将所有的资金投入到这些军事冒险中。其中最著名的就是三十年战争中的古斯塔夫·阿道夫（Gustavus Adolphus），我认为这是大北方战争的某种先驱，因为当你看着地图时，你会想：瑞典人在巴伐利亚或者他们所在的任何地方到底在干什么？
they are? It's kind of just roaming madly like they're basically playing a video game or something. Well, it's interesting because today we associate Sweden with pacifism and neutrality. Yeah. But there are two great periods of kind of military efflorescence in Swedish history, which the Vikings is obviously the first. Yeah. But this is the second through the 17th and early 18th century. They are marauding all over Europe.
这简直就像是在疯狂地闲逛，就像他们在玩电子游戏一样。嗯，这很有趣，因为今天我们将瑞典与和平主义和中立联系在一起。是的。但瑞典历史上曾有过两个伟大的军事大爆发时期，维京人显然是第一个。是的。但这是第二个，贯穿了 17 世纪和 18 世纪初。他们在整个欧洲四处掠夺。
And they behave, they're incredibly fearsome. I mean, if the Swedes turn up, if you're living in a sort of small German town and the Swedish army appears on the hill, you're like, oh no, because they always behave with unbelievable brutality and sort of no quarter and all that kind of thing. Anyway, by 1700, they control not just the Baltic, they control much of Norway, they control parts of northern Germany as well, so Bremen, Wismar, Western Pomerania, these are all effectively Swedish possessions. So the Baltic effectively is a Swedish lake. It is, exactly. Exactly. And what lies behind all this is what's probably at the time the
他们的行为极其令人生畏。我的意思是，如果瑞典人出现——如果你住在某个德国小镇，而瑞典军队出现在山丘上——你就会想：哦不！因为他们的行动总是伴随着难以置信的残酷，不留活口诸如此类。总之，到了 1700 年，他们不仅控制了波罗的海，还控制了挪威的大部分地区，以及德国北部的部分地区，比如不来梅、维斯马、西波美拉尼亚，这些实际上都是瑞典的领地。所以波罗的海实际上成了瑞典的内湖。确实如此，完全如此。这一切背后的支撑，可以说是当时
world's most advanced, most efficient killing machine, the Swedish army. So the 17th century, early 18th century, the age of the military revolution as it's called, firearms, forts, huge armies, far, far bigger than anything at the dawn of the 17th century. And Gustavus Adolphus is the guy who's really the kind of, he's the great military innovator. He is one of the great progenitors of this. What backs it up? You need an infrastructure of organisation, of training, of drilling and finance and a state and a bureaucracy. So in other words, the military revolution
世界上最先进、最高效的杀戮机器——瑞典军队。因此，17 世纪、18 世纪初，也就是所谓的军事革命时代，火器、堡垒、庞大的军队，远远比 17 世纪初的任何规模都要大得多。而古斯塔夫·阿道夫正是真正意义上的那个伟大的军事创新者。他是这一切的伟大鼻祖之一。是什么支撑了这一切？你需要组织、训练、操练以及财政、国家和官僚机构的基础设施。换句话说，军事革命
rewards countries with very well organised tax raising bureaucracies. So Sweden and then England later on, of course. And the consequence of that is that you can have a standing army, which hasn't been seen really in Europe since the Roman Empire. Exactly. And you have, what is it? The pikemen can also fire with flintlocks and it's kind of this idea that you stab and you shoot at the same time. That's right with bayonets. The bayonet is a key thing. And so that becomes
回报了那些拥有组织极其完善、能够征税的官僚机构的国家。因此是瑞典，当然还有后来的英国。而这带来的结果就是，你可以拥有一支常备军，这在罗马帝国之后欧洲基本上是未曾见过的。确实如此。而且你拥有——这是什么？长矛兵也可以用燧发枪开火，这是一种边刺杀边射击的理念。没错，用刺刀。刺刀是一个关键因素。所以这成为了
the new innovation, doesn't it? That replaces the pike. But essentially it's terrifying, as you said, to be confronted with this very, very menacing military machine. Yeah. Modern, I think it's also a mod. It's a really modern military machine. So the Swedes are pioneers of, so your, your brother's podcast would enjoy this combined arms operations. So infantry cavalry and artillery working really closely together. And you can only do that if they're perfectly drilled, very well organized.
新的创新，不是吗？它取代了长矛。但本质上，正如你所说，面对这台非常、非常具有威胁性的军事机器是令人畏惧的。是的。现代，我认为这也是一架现代军事机器。所以瑞典人是——所以你弟弟的播客会喜欢这个——联合兵种作战的先驱。步兵、骑兵和炮兵紧密配合。只有在他们经过完美操练、组织得非常好的情况下，你才能做到这一点。
Everybody knows their place in the plan. The Swedes also, I think have a kind of, there's a religious dimension. Well, that's why they're in the 30 years war. That's why they're in the 30 years war. Exactly. So they're Lutherans. Some historians say it gives them a sense, not just a mission, but a kind of fatalism. Charles the 12th, who we'll come to, famously said, I shall fall by no other bullet than that, which is destined for me.
每个人都知道自己在计划中的位置。我认为瑞典人也有某种——有一种宗教维度。哦，这就是为什么他们在三十年战争中。这就是为什么他们在三十年战争中。没错。所以他们是路德宗信徒。一些历史学家说，这赋予了他们一种意识，不仅是一种使命感，还有一种宿命论。我们稍后会谈到的十二世查理曾有一句名言：除了为我注定落下的那颗子弹外，我不会死于任何其他子弹。
And when that comes, no prudence will help me. In other words, there's no point me trying to save myself or to worry about the risks. God has already decided and there's no point in me stressing about it. I'll just die when I die and that bullet has been prepared somewhere and there's no point me even stressing about it. But also if God has chosen you to be his sword, then you have to surrender to that sense of purpose. And that's something that Charles obviously embodies, but Gustavus had as well. And actually, Dominic, when I went to see Astenwiller play against Leipzig, I took the opportunity to pop
当那一刻来临的时候，任何审慎都帮不了我。换句话说，我试图自救或担心风险是毫无意义的。上帝已经做出了决定，为这件事焦虑毫无意义。我该死的时候自然会死，那颗子弹已经在某处备好了，我甚至没有必要为此感到压力。但同时，如果上帝选择了你作为他的长剑，那么你必须顺从那种使命感。这是查理显然体现出来的东西，古斯塔夫也有。事实上，多米尼克，当我去观看阿斯顿维拉对阵莱比锡的比赛时，我趁机去了
up to Wittenberg. And in the church there, there was a plaque marking where Gustavus Adolphus' coffin had been laid as it was brought back from the depths of Germany. And that sense of cutting edge military efficiency and kind of religious certitude, I mean, is a terrifying combination. Yeah, I think absolutely. And nobody incarnates it better than Charles XII. So he was 10 years younger than Peter the Great. He's born in 1682. His father, Charles the 11th, was very pious and had trained him from birth effectively for war. So when he's four years old, he's riding behind his father at military reviews. At six years old,
维滕贝格。在那里的教堂里，有一块牌匾，标明了古斯塔夫·阿道夫的棺材在从德国腹地运回时曾停放过的地方。这种尖端的军事效率与宗教的确信感相结合，我的天，是一个可怕的组合。是的，绝对如此。没有人比十二世查理更能体现这一点了。他比彼得大帝小 10 岁。他出生于 1682 年。他的父亲十一世查理非常虔诚，实际上从他出生起就对其实施军事训练。所以当他四岁时，他就骑马跟在父亲身后参加阅兵式。六岁时，
he's taken away from his mother in the ladies court and he's given to military and male tutors. At seven, he shoots his first fox at eight. What is it about foxes? Kings of Northern Europe are just terrible towards foxes. Augustus the strong, the fox tosser from the last episode. He'll be reappearing in this in the next couple of episodes. So when he was eight, Charles killed his first deer. When he was 10, he killed a wolf. And when he was 11, he killed his first bear. He loves killing bears.
他被带离了母亲和宫廷女眷，交给了军事和男性导师。七岁时，他射杀了第一只狐狸，八岁时——狐狸是怎么回事？北欧的国王们对狐狸简直糟透了。上一集里那个抛狐狸的强力王奥古斯都。他将在接下来几集的这一集里再次出现。所以当他八岁时，查理杀死了他的第一头鹿。十岁时，他杀死了一头狼。十一岁时，他杀死了第一头熊。他喜欢杀熊。
There is a lot of bear murder in this episode, isn't there? He's a very terse, serious, stoical man, a young man. He's obsessed with honor. He's obsessed with his own integrity. He's very bright. He reads Latin. He reads Moliere and Racine in the original. Every morning he spends an hour discussing the Bible with a bishop. And he carries a biography
这一集里有大量的猎熊情节，不是吗？他是一个非常言简意赅、严肃、坚忍的人，一个年轻人。他痴迷于荣誉。他痴迷于自己的正直。他非常聪明。他读拉丁语。他阅读原版的莫里哀和拉辛。每天早晨，他都要花一个小时与一位主教讨论圣经。他随身携带
of Alexander the Great with him wherever he goes, which is rather like, didn't Alexander the Great have a special box? Then he traveled with the Iliad. So this is effectively, you know, he models himself in Alexander and you can actually see his mad campaigns do have that that sort of Alexandrian spirit. Well, that's what Samuel Johnson's poem is doing because it's echoing a satire by juvenile, the Roman poet. And so he's casting him very much as a kind of classical hero. Yes, like a Hannibal. Like a Hannibal, very explicitly like a Hannibal. Yeah. So when he's 15, Charles, he succeeds the throne because his father dies young.
一本亚历山大大帝的传记，走到哪带到哪，这有点像——亚历山大不是有一个特殊的盒子吗？他带着《伊利亚特》旅行。所以实际上，你知道，他以亚历山大为自己的模范，你确实可以看到他那些疯狂的战役带有那种亚历山大式的精神。嗯，这就是塞缪尔·约翰逊的诗所做的事情，因为它呼应了罗马诗人尤维纳利斯的讽刺作品。因此，他非常将查理塑造成一种古典英雄。是的，就像汉尼拔一样。就像汉尼拔，非常明确地就像汉尼拔。是的。所以当他 15 岁时，查理继承了王位，因为他的父亲英年早逝。
And they originally, they say, well, they have a regency council because he's so young. Within months, he scraps that and says, no, I want to run everything myself. And a sign of his character is that when he rides to his coronation, he says, I will not be crowned king at my coronation because I consider myself king already. So no one else will crown me. And he actually rides to the service with the crown already on his head, which lots of people find quite shocking, but it is a sign of his sort of willfulness. You know, he will shape history to his designs rather than allow history to kind of happen to
起初他们说，好吧，他们设立了一个摄政委员会，因为他太年轻了。几个月内，他就废除了这个委员会，并说：不，我想自己掌管一切。他性格的一个标志是，当他骑马去参加加冕典礼时，他说：我不会在加冕典礼上加冕为王，因为我认为自己已经是国王了。所以没有人能为我加冕。事实上，他头上戴着王冠骑马去参加礼拜，这让许多人感到相当震惊，但这也是他那种任性的标志。你知道，他宁愿按照自己的意图塑造历史，也不愿让历史任由摆布，可以说是这样的。
him as it were. But also presumably it illustrates his sense that he has been chosen by God and he doesn't need a church to mediate between that. Exactly right, exactly. And I think that sense of being chosen by God also fuels his extraordinary courage. That point about, you know, the bullet has already been chosen that will kill me. Because as a teenage king, you know, he ignores all the advisors who say, who's your heir, you need to kind of take care of yourself, all of this kind of thing. He will get up early and he will go off riding through the snow with a page kind of leaping over walls. He loves to rate to sledge, to have kind of sledge races. He loves hunting bears with armed only with a wooden pitchfork.
但这也大概说明了他认为自己是上帝拣选的，不需要教会来进行中介。完全正确，完全正确。我认为这种被上帝拣选的感觉也助长了他非凡的勇气。关于“那颗将杀死我的子弹已经被选定”的那一点。因为作为一个十几岁的国王，你知道，他忽视了所有那些对他说“谁是你的继承人，你需要照顾好自己”诸如此类的顾问。他会早起，和侍童一起骑马穿过雪地，跳过墙壁。他喜欢骑雪橇，进行雪橇比赛。他喜欢只用一柄木质草叉去猎熊。
Yeah, that's mad, isn't it? He kind of, he gets the bear in the fork and then he leaps on it and throttles it. And then just insane behavior. So people who worry, you know, that sort of teenage boys are spending too much time in their basements playing on video games and not getting it. I mean, they would learn. This is the model of somebody who gets out, enjoys the great outdoors, tests himself, finds an outlet for his kind of burgeoning masculinity.
是的，太疯狂了，不是吗？他用草叉叉住那头熊，然后扑上去掐死它。简直是疯狂的行为。所以那些担心青少年花太多时间在地下室玩电子游戏、没有经历现实生活的人——我的这就是一个榜样，他走出去，享受大自然，考验自己，为自己蓬勃的男子气概找到一个宣泄口。
And doesn't he, he's on a horse and he just rides off a cliff just for the, just for the bands. There's a lot of stuff like that. Like Peter the Great, he loves war games and he'll have war games at sea with kind of water cannons instead of real cannons. And at one point he sees one of his friends swimming and he says, and he can't swim and he says, that looks like it's quite easy, is it? And says, yeah, it's very easy.
而且，他不是骑在马上，仅仅为了——为了好玩就直接骑马冲下悬崖吗？有很多类似的事情。就像彼得大帝一样，他喜欢战争游戏，他会用能够发射水炮而不是真炮的水上战争游戏。有一次，他看到他的一个朋友在游泳，而那个人不会游泳，他就问：看起来挺容易的，是吗？那个人说：是的，非常容易。
And he jumps into the Baltic and then almost drowns and has to be dragged out. But that's exactly his vibe. I mean, just jumping into the Baltic on its own is mad. Now the interesting thing, some historians have subsequently said they think he was gay because he never married and he never had any, as far as we can tell, any relationship of any kind. I think that's probably wrong because there's no evidence that he was gay or that he, because he said again and again, I am married to the army.
于是他跳进波罗的海，结果差点淹死，不得不被人拉捞出来。但这正是他的风格。我的意思是，单单是跳进波罗的海就已经够疯狂了。现在有趣的是，一些历史学家后来表示，他们认为他是同性恋，因为他从未结婚，而且据我们所知，他从未有过任何形式的恋爱关系。我认为这可能是错的，因为没有证据表明他是同性恋，也没有证据表明他——因为他曾反复说过：我嫁给了军队。
I will not settle down until I've, you I've wiped the floor with the rest of Europe. There was a moment when it looked like he might have an interesting career as a prankster on the level of Peter the Great. So in 1698, his cousin, the Duke of Holstein Gotthorpe came to Stockholm to marry Charles's sister and they got up to all kinds of amusing japs. They set wild hairs loose in the Swedish parliament and chased them through the parliament. They used the palace windows of pistol practice. They threw cherries at Charles' ministers. They rode through the streets knocking people's
在我把整个欧洲踩在脚下之前，我是不会安定下来的。曾有一段时间，他看起来可能会在彼得大帝级别的恶作剧方面拥有一个有趣的职业生涯。因此，在 1698 年，他的表弟荷尔斯泰因-戈托普（Holstein-Gottorp）公爵来到斯德哥尔摩迎娶查理的姐姐，他们搞出了各种有趣的恶作剧。他们把野兔放进瑞典议会，并在议会里追赶它们。他们把宫殿的窗户当成手枪射击练习靶。他们向查理的大臣们扔樱桃。他们骑马穿过街道，打落人们的
hats off and stealing their wigs. And they also, the best bit, which I think is apocryphal to be fair, is they had a competition to see who could behead the most sheep in a specific stretch of time. Isn't there also more bear action? They get a bear drunk. That's right. They did get a bear drunk. And push it out of the window. That's right. Yeah. This was called the Gotthorpe Fury. It was like this was one last binge. It was like a bit of a stag do. One last binge before a life of domesticity. By the time Charles turned 18 in 1700,
帽子并偷走他们的假发。还有最精彩的部分——公平地说，这可能是一个杜撰的故事——他们进行了一场比赛，看谁能在特定的时间内砍掉最多只羊的头。难道还有更多的猎熊动作吗？他们把一头熊灌醉了。没错。他们确实把一头熊灌醉了。然后把它推出窗外。没错。是的。这被称为“戈托普狂怒”（Gotthorpe Fury）。这就像是最后一次狂欢。就像是一场单身派对。在迎来过上家庭生活的一生之前，进行最后一次狂欢。到了 1700 年查理满 18 岁时，
he's put all the pranks behind him. He's become very serious. He's given up drinking strong liquor. He sleeps half of every night on the floor to toughen himself up. In winter, he sleeps in a barn to prepare himself for life on campaign. And he's also ashamed of being very fair skinned and spends loads of time trying to get sunburned in order to, again, to kind of toughen his skin up. So very, very Spartan sort of ethos. And you could argue, I suppose, now if you were a Dane or something, you would say this is absolutely typical of the Swedes, wouldn't you? Because the Danes have very discerning views of the Swedes.
他已经把所有的恶作剧抛在脑后。他变得非常严肃。他戒掉了烈酒。他每晚有一半的时间睡在地板上以磨练自己。冬天，他睡在谷仓里，为军旅生活做准备。而且他为自己皮肤白皙感到羞耻，花大量时间试图把自己晒黑，再次为了锻炼自己的皮肤。所以这是一种非常非常斯巴达式的精神气质。你可以辩称，如果你是一个丹麦人或者其他什么人，你可能会说这绝对是瑞典人的典型特征，不是吗？因为丹麦人对瑞典人有着非常挑剔的看法。
They think they're all sort of cold, driven, obsessive. And there is a little bit of that, I think, about Charles and possibly you could argue about Sweden generally at this point, because you could argue- I think it's very impressive. A commitment to ascetic militarism. I'm not a very ascetic person deep down, but I kind of wish that I was. You know, I'd like to be more Swedish generally, I think. There is a downside to this and this is partly what brings on the Great Northern War. Sweden held the province of Livonia which is now kind of Estonia and Latvia since 1660. It was dominated by Baltic German barons who were the descendants of the Teutonic Knights. We do love a Baltic German baron.
他们认为他们都是那种冷酷、driven（有驱动力的）、执着的人。我认为查理身上确实有一点这种特质，可能你也可以普遍认为此时的瑞典也是如此，因为你可以争辩说——我认为这非常令人印象深刻。对苦行军国主义的执着。我内心深处并不是一个很苦行的人，但我有时希望自己是。你知道，我希望自己整体上更瑞典化一些，我想。这也有不好的一面，而这部分也是导致大北方战争爆发的原因。自 1660 年以来，瑞典一直控制着立窝尼亚（Livonia）省，也就是现在的爱沙尼亚和拉脱维亚一带。这里由条顿骑士团后裔的波罗的海德国男爵统治。我们确实很爱波罗的海德国男爵。
Yeah, you've got to love a Baltic German baron. But over time the Swedes had been kind of whittling away at the powers of these Baltic German Barons and confiscating their lands and generally making themselves very unpopular. And the spokesman for the Baltic Barons was a guy called Johann Reinhard von Patkohl. And he was, you know, a tremendous fellow. He's very intelligent. He's very brave, dashing. He's fluent in Greek and Latin. And the Baltic chaps sent him to Stockholm. They said, go and plead our case in Stockholm and say, like, stop confiscating our lands
对，你不得不爱一个波罗的海德国男爵。但随着时间的推移，瑞典人一直在削弱这些波罗的海德国男爵的权力，没收他们的土地，并普遍让自己变得非常不受欢迎。而波罗的海男爵们的发言人是一个名叫约翰·赖因哈德·冯·帕特库尔（Johann Reinhard von Patkul）的人。他是一个了不起的人物。他非常聪明，非常勇敢，意气风发。他精通希腊语和拉丁语。波罗的海的家伙们派他去斯德哥尔摩。他们说：去斯德哥尔摩替我们申诉，说类似于“停止没收我们的土地
and being nasty to us. And when he arrived in Stockholm, the Swedes, living up to their reputation in Europe in the 17th century, they said, you're obviously a terrible man. No one cares what you think. And they sentenced him to death. So he fled West in disguise and he then spent the next sort of months and years plotting to build an anti-Swedish coalition. And he went first to the King of Denmark, Frederick IV.
并对我们不好”之类的话。当他到达斯德哥尔摩时，瑞典人完全不负他们在 17 世纪欧洲的声誉，他们说：你显然是个糟糕透顶的人。没人关心你的想法。于是他们判处他死刑。所以他伪装后向西逃亡，并在接下来的几个月和几年里，密谋建立一个反瑞典联盟。他首先去找了丹麦国王腓特烈四世（Frederick IV）。
The Danes hate the Swedes. They want to get the province of Skåne in southern Sweden back. That's the place you see in Wallander in the TV series. Yes, Henning Mankell. Yeah. So they want to get Skåne back and the Danes are well in. Then he goes to see our old friend, Fox tossing champion, Augustus the Strong. Augustus the Strong has only recently been elected King of Poland and he's very keen to impress their Polish nobles. And so that's on top of him being electro-Saxony.
丹麦人痛恨瑞典人。他们想要收回瑞典南部的斯科讷（Skåne）省。也就是你在电视剧《维兰德》（Wallander）里看到的那个地方。是的，海宁·曼凯尔（Henning Mankell）。所以他们想夺回斯科讷，而丹麦人对此非常热心。然后他去见了我们的老朋友、抛狐狸冠军强力王奥古斯都。强力王奥古斯都不久前刚刚当选波兰国王，他非常急于给波兰贵族留下深刻印象。所以这还不算他身兼萨克森选帝侯的身份。
Electro-Saxony as well. He's stacking up the titles. Exactly. And he loves the thought of conquering Livonia, Estonia and Latvia. And Pat Cole says to him, look, you know, when we build this coalition, it's going to be dead easy. I mean, he genuinely says you'll be in Riga for Christmas. He's not aware of Peter the Great's Riga obsession.
同时也是萨克森选帝侯。他头衔越堆越多。没错。而且他一想到要征服立窝尼亚、爱沙尼亚和拉脱维亚就兴奋不已。帕特库尔对他说：听着，当我们建立这个联盟时，这将是轻而易举的事。我的意思是，他真心实意地对他说：你圣诞节前就能到里加了。他并不知道彼得大帝对里加的执念。
Yeah, exactly. So Frederick and Augustus agree this deal. The Danes will attack the Swedes in North Germany and then Skuna, southern Sweden, and Augustus will march troops from Saxony, his Saxon army, and maybe some Poles into Livonia. So the Swedes will be fighting two different adversaries on two different fronts and they'll be overwhelmed. And then Pat Cole, the guy who's put this together, says, look, we can actually go one better.
是的，完全如此。于是腓特烈和奥古斯都达成了一项协议。丹麦人将进攻德国北部的瑞典人，然后进攻瑞典南部的斯科讷；而奥古斯都将率领来自萨克森的军队（他的萨克森军队）以及一些波兰人挺进立窝尼亚。这样瑞典人就得在两个不同的战线上与两个不同的敌人作战，他们会被压垮。然后，促成这一切的帕特库尔说：听着，我们其实可以做得更好。
Why don't we get Peter the Great in on this as well? We'll get the Russians to attack in Ingria, the area now around St. Petersburg, and that will distract the Swedes from defending Riga. And this will be great. Now, the thing is that when they put this deal together, everybody thinks of the Russians as a sort of slightly ludicrous junior partner because the Russians never win wars and Patka actually says to the polls, the Russian infantry would be most serviceable for working in the trenches and for receiving the enemy's shots.
为什么我们不把彼得大帝也拉进来呢？我们让俄罗斯人进攻英格里亚——也就是现在圣彼得堡周边的地区，这将分散瑞典人防守里加的兵力，这会很棒。问题是，当他们达成这项协议时，所有人都把俄罗斯人视为一个有点滑稽的小伙伴，因为俄罗斯人从不赢得战争。帕特库尔甚至对波兰人说：俄罗斯步兵最适合在战壕里干活以及承受敌人的子弹。
In other words, they really will be cannon fodder. the enemy's shots. In other words, they really will be cannon fodder. But they don't think it's a bad idea to give the Russians access to the Baltic. They don't think this is, I mean, a kind of foolish step. They're aware that there's a slight risk actually. So Pat Coles says to the Poles at one point, we have to bind the hands of the Tsar so he doesn't get in or hit ahead of us. Obviously, we don't want him to take Estonia and Latvia. We don't want him to take Tallinn and Riga and all of that, because that's really destined for Poland.
换句话说，他们真的只是炮灰。敌人的子弹。换句话说，他们真的只是炮灰。但他们并不认为让俄罗斯人获得通往波罗的海的通道是个坏主意。他们不认为这是一个愚蠢的举动。他们意识到其实存在一点风险。所以帕特库尔曾在某个时候对波兰人说：我们必须绑住沙皇的手，这样他就不会抢先或者抢在我们前面。显然，我们不想让他夺走爱沙尼亚和拉脱维亚。我们不想让他夺走塔林、里加以及所有这些地方，因为那真的是留给波兰的。
So they are kind of aware, I think, that there's a danger. But just to be clear, they are offering him the region where in the long runs in Petersburg will be. Yes. They are giving him that window onto the Baltic Sea. But right at the very end of the Baltic, it doesn't occur to them that he would end up with Estonia and Latvia as well,
所以他们某种程度上意识到其中存在危险。但需要明确的是，他们正在把日后将成为圣彼得堡的那个地区提供给他。是的。他们给了他一扇通往波罗的海的窗户。但在波罗的海的最边缘，他们没想到他最终会连爱沙尼亚和拉脱维亚也一起收入囊中，
but they'll give him a little foothold. That's the bribe basically. By the beginning of 1700, the deal is done. The Poles, well, I said the Poles, it's actually Saxon troops that Augustus the Strong is using. He sends them in first into what's now Latvia to besiege Riga. A few weeks later, the Danes strike into Holstein, so in North Germany. And as we've seen, in August, Peter the Great joins the war as well. Now they think Charles is only a teenager. We can wipe the floor with this bloke. He's just a stripling and they're quite wrong of course. Charles is in the forest and
不过他们会给他一个小据点。这基本上就是贿赂。到 1700 年初，这笔交易敲定了。波兰人——好吧，我说是波兰人，实际上强力王奥古斯都使用的是萨克森军队。他首先派他们进入现在的拉脱维亚去围攻里加。几周后，丹麦人突袭了荷尔斯泰因，也就是德国北部。正如我们所见，在 8 月，彼得大帝也加入了战争。现在他们认为查理只是个少年。我们可以把这家伙踩在脚下。他只是个乳臭未干的小伙子。当然，他们大错特错了。查理当时在森林里，
guess what he's doing? He's hunting bears. Oh god, more bear murdering. I know. When news comes that Augustus has struck, he greets the news completely calmly and he says, well, we'll make King Augustus go back the way he came. And then later he gets the news a few weeks later, the Danes have joined the war as well. And he says, it's curious that both my cousins, Frederick and Augustus, wish to make war on me. So be it. But King Augustus has broken his word. Our cause then is just and God will help us. There's a sort of very admirable Stoicism, certainty and calm about Charles, which has, as we will see, has a dark side if you're too certain of victory in war. Yeah.
你猜他在干什么？他在猎熊。天哪，又在谋杀熊。我知道。当奥古斯都发动进攻的消息传到时，他表现得极其冷静，并说：好吧，我们会让奥古斯都国王从哪来回哪去。然后几周后他又得到了消息，丹麦也加入了战争。他说：真奇怪，我的两个表弟，腓特烈和奥古斯都，都想对我开战。那就这样吧。但奥古斯都国王违背了诺言。所以我们的事业是正义的，上帝会保佑我们。查理身上有一种非常令人钦佩的坚忍、坚定和冷静，正如我们将看到的，如果你对战争中的胜利过于确信，这也是有黑暗面的一向的。是的。
But he spells out his kind of sense of mission to his council, doesn't he? He says, I have resolved never to begin an unjust war, but also never to end a just war without overcoming my enemy. So essentially he is committing himself to a war to the death. He says, I will not stop until I've got my revenge and these cousins have finally attacked me, you know, have paid the price. And a big spoiler alert, Charles will have multiple opportunities to end the war on not terribly disadvantageous terms, but he refuses them all. He says, no, no, no, no, we go right to the end on this.
但他向他的议会阐明了他的使命感，不是吗？他说：我已决心绝不挑起一场不义之战，但也绝不以不战胜敌人来结束一场正义之战。所以本质上，他是在承诺一场至死方休的战争。他说：在复仇、在这些胆敢攻击我的表弟们付出代价之前，我绝不会停手。剧透警告，查理将有多次机会在并非极其不利的条件下结束战争，但他拒绝了所有这些机会。他说：不，不，不，不，我们在这件事上要硬磕到底。
You know, I've been wronged and there'll be absolutely no compromise whatsoever. So on the 13th of April 1700, Charles leaves Stockholm, says goodbye to his closest relatives who are his grandmother and his sister and believe it or not, he will never see them or Stockholm. But at first, the war goes brilliantly for Charles. It's pretty obvious that this allied coalition have completely underestimated him and miscalculated. Instead of dividing his forces as they thought he would, he does the sensible thing. He keeps his forces together and he deals with his enemies one by one. So first, he smites the Danes. The Danes have
你知道，我受到了委屈，绝对没有任何妥协的余地。因此，在 1700 年 4 月 13 日，查理离开斯德哥尔摩，向他最亲近的亲人——他的祖母和姐姐告别。信不信由你，他将再也见不到她们和斯德哥尔摩了。但起初，战争对查理来说进展得极其顺利。很明显，这个盟军同盟完全低估了他，并严重误算。他没有像他们想象的那样分兵，而是做了明智的事情。他将兵力集中在一起，一个接一个地收拾敌人。首先，他痛击了丹麦人。丹麦人表现得
behaved very foolishly. They've sent all their army into Holstein to try and capture it, which means that when he lands his army in Zeeland and marches on Copenhagen, they're completely helpless. So within months, he's knocked the Danes out of the war completely. I mean, they've had what Theo would call, they have had a shocker. Next is Peter the Great. Peter the Great's initial objective was the coastal fortress of Narva, which is now, I think it's on the border of Estonia and Russia. And Russia had ruled it fleetingly, I think, in the 16th century. It had a very classic kind of Baltic story.
非常愚蠢。他们把所有的军队都派往荷尔斯泰因试图将其攻占，这意味着当他把军队在西兰岛登陆并向哥本哈根进军时，他们完全无计可施。因此，几个月内，他就彻底将丹麦人打出了战争。我的意思是，他们遭遇了西奥（Theo）所说的惨败。接下来是彼得大帝。彼得大帝最初的目标是沿海要塞纳尔瓦（Narva），我想它现在位于爱沙尼亚和俄罗斯的边界上。俄罗斯曾在 16 世纪短暂地统治过它。它有着非常典型的波罗的海故事。
It originally Danish, Baltic German, but had briefly been Russian, and now it's Swedish. And, you know, Peter turns up, he arrives with 40,000 men. Now, most of these, or a lot of these, are his play soldiers that he had had in the previous episodes. So the people he'd been training in his teens. But I guess the majority are serfs, conscripted Russian serfs. They're not really professional soldiers at all. They look good because he's put them in what he calls German uniform. They were dark green coats and they were black tricorn hats. So no caftans. No caftans.
它最初是丹麦的、波罗的海德国人的，但曾短暂属于俄罗斯，现在则是瑞典的。你知道，彼得出现了，他带着 40,000 人抵达。现在，其中大部分或者很多都是他在前几集里拥有的玩具士兵。也就是他在青少年时期一直在训练的人。但我猜大多数都是农奴，被强征的俄罗斯农奴。他们根本不是真正的职业军人。他们看起来不错，因为他给他们穿上了他所谓的德式军服。他们穿着深绿色的大衣，戴着黑色的三角帽。所以没有卡夫坦长袍（caftans）。没有卡夫坦长袍。
Absolutely no caftans and no beards. But they really just don't know what they're doing. They arrive outside Narva at the end of 1700. The siege goes very, very slowly. It's raining. They're all very miserable. And then stunning news to their disbelief. Charles has landed in Southern Estonia with 10,000 men and he's marching on Nava.
绝对没有卡夫坦长袍，也没有胡须。但他们真的不知道自己在干什么。他们在 1700 年底抵达纳尔瓦城外。围城战进展得非常非常慢。下着雨。大家都非常痛苦。然后，令人难以置信的震撼消息传来：查理带着 10,000 人在爱沙尼亚南部登陆，正向纳尔瓦进军。
And they've got 40,000. But this thing you see, when we go through all these numbers, the Russians always have more, but they're absolutely terrified of the Swedes. Because everybody says, well, you can't beat the Swedes. You could have a hundred thousand men and you won't beat 10,000 Swedes because they're brilliant. They're so well organized. They've got the latest muskets. They've got bayonets. They've got God. You know, you might as well just run away right now. They are super troopers. They are super troopers. Very good. I like to think there'll be a lot of ABBA puns in this series. By the time Charles reaches Narva, Peter himself
而他们有 40,000 人。但你看，当我们浏览所有这些数字时，俄罗斯人总是占多数，但他们对瑞典人畏惧如虎。因为每个人都说：嗯，你打不过瑞典人。你就算有一十万人，也打不过一万名瑞典人，因为他们太优秀了。他们组织得太好了。他们有最新的滑膛枪。他们有刺刀。他们有上帝。你知道，你现在最好赶紧逃跑。他们是超级战士。他们是超级战士。非常棒。我希望这个系列里能有很多关于 ABBA 的双关语。当查理到达纳尔瓦时，彼得本人
was already gone. He's actually gone to get reinforcements from Novgorod, but this is a very bad look because it looks like he's run away. No, I mean, Peter the Great, he's insanely brave. He is, but you know what? I mean, this is terrible PR for Peter. The Swedes, as you said, are outnumbered four to one, but they basically absolutely wipe the floor with the Russians. The Russians lost 9,000 men killed and wounded and 20,000 men captured and all their artillery captured. The Swedes lost fewer than 700 men.
已经离开。他其实去诺夫哥罗德增援去了，但这看起来非常糟糕，因为这看起来就像是他逃跑了。不，我的意思是，彼得大帝，他极其勇敢。他是很勇敢，但你知道吗？我的意思是，这对彼得来说是糟糕透顶的公关。瑞典人，正如你所说，在人数上以一敌四，但他们基本上把俄罗斯人打得落花流水。俄罗斯人死伤 9,000 人，被俘 20,000 人，并且他们所有的火炮都被缴获了。瑞典人阵亡不到 700 人。
So the Swedes just win a massive victory. It's a huge humiliation for Peter. And the Swedes then struck a medal, a medallion that showed Peter running away. And it had two biblical quotations. On one side it said, Peter stood and warmed himself. And on the other side, it says, he went out and wept bitterly. And obviously for Peter, who's very proud, this is a big deal. Being teased by Lutherans. Exactly. An Orthodox, yeah, an Orthodox Tsar of Russia would not like
所以瑞典人赢得了巨大的胜利。这对彼得来说是一个巨大的羞辱。随后瑞典人铸造了一枚勋章，上面刻着彼得逃跑的图案。上面有两句《圣经》引文。一面写着：彼得站着烤火。另一面写着：他出去痛哭流涕。显然，对于非常高傲的彼得来说，这是一件大事。被路德宗信徒嘲笑。没错。一个东正教的——是的，一个俄罗斯的东正教沙皇绝对不会喜欢这个。
that at all. For Charles, who's obviously 10 years younger than Peter, he's won his first big battle and he absolutely loves it. And he's been doing exactly as you would expect. He's been riding around in full view of the Russian guns. He's been taunting their gunners and snipers. He's had horses shot from under him. He is living the dream. It's just what he's always wanted. There were descriptions of him at the time by other Swedes. They say he seemed drunk with happiness at the end of that battle, but he complained. He said, there was no pleasure in fighting with the Russians for they will not stand
对查理来说，他显然比彼得小 10 岁，他赢得了他的第一场大战，他对此喜爱有加。他一直在做你所期望的事情。他一直在俄军火枪的射程内骑马巡视。他在嘲笑他们的炮手和狙击手。他身下的战马被枪杀。他正在过着梦想中的生活。这正是他一直想要的。当时其他瑞典人对他的描述是，那场战役结束时，他看起来因幸福而陶醉，但他抱怨说：跟俄罗斯人打仗一点乐趣都没有，因为他们根本不肯坚守阵地。
like other men, but they run away at once. The massive downside, I think this first battle gives Charles a total contempt for Peter and for the Russians and a really, really dangerous belief in his own invincibility. He just thinks that I will never lose. I love this. This is brilliant. It's everything I've dreamed of and I can't possibly lose. I'd like as much of it as possible, please. And actually one of his officers said even at this point, a guy called Count Stenbok, he said, the king thinks now about nothing except war. He no longer troubles himself about the advice of other people and he seems to believe that God communicates directly to him what he ought to do. So our Catholic and Orthodox listeners may well say this is the great downside having a Protestant
像其他男人一样，但他们立刻就逃跑了。我认为，这场初战带来的巨大负面影响是，查理对彼得、对俄国人产生了彻底的蔑视，并且对他自己战无不胜的信念产生了非常非常危险的执念。他只是认为我永远不会输。我喜欢这样。这太棒了。这是我梦想中的一切，我绝不可能输。请给我尽可能多的这种感觉，拜局。事实上，他的一位军官甚至在当时就说过，一个叫斯坦博克伯爵的人，他说，国王现在除了战争什么都不想。他不再为别人的意见而烦恼，他似乎相信上帝直接向他传达了他应该做的事情。因此，我们的天主教和东正教听众可能会说，拥有一个新教
military leader, because he's in direct communication with the Almighty. And this can lead you astray. Robert K. Massey, Peter's great biographer, says, in this sense, while Narva was Charles's first great victory, it was also the first step towards his doom. Goodness. So we will have a break now and Dominic when we come back,
军事领袖是一个巨大的缺点，因为他与全能者直接沟通。这可能会把你引入歧途。彼得的伟大传记作家罗伯特·K·马西（Robert K. Massey）说，从这个意义上说，纳尔瓦虽然是查理的第一次伟大胜利，但这也是他走向毁灭的第一步。天哪。所以我们现在休息一下，多米尼克，当我们回来时，
let's find out how the Great Northern War continues. Hello, welcome back to The Rest of History and while you have been listening to those adverts or not listening to the adverts, of if you are a member of the Restless History Club. Dominic, the Great Northern War has been cracking on two years have passed and essentially it's turned into something reminiscent of the First World War, hasn't it? A kind of attritional slog. It has indeed. So we don't normally do this, but the Great Northern War is so long that we've skipped two years in the break. So what's happened in the meantime is that Peter has gone, has not panicked after losing the battle of Narva. He has got a top general, commander in chief, uh, who's a veteran diplomat.
让我们来看看大北方战争是如何继续的。你好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》（The Rest of History），在你一直在听这些广告或者没有听这些广告的时候，或者如果你是“历史的其余部分俱乐部”的会员的话。多米尼克，大北方战争已经打了好几年了，两年过去了，它本质上已经变成了一种让人想起第一次世界大战的东西，不是吗？一种消耗战。确实如此。所以我们通常不这样做，但大北方战争太长了，我们在中场休息时跳过了两年。与此同时发生的事情是彼得已经走了，在输掉纳尔瓦战役后并没有惊慌失措。他找了一个顶级的将军、总司令，嗯，他是一位经验丰富的外交官，
He's very pro modernizing and whatnot, who is called Boris Sheremetyev. And so he's the, the, the Zhukov of this story. He is exactly. He is, he is the, he is the guy who is going to basically marshal Russia's enormous manpower to try to fight off this kind of supposedly invincible Swedish killing machine. I mean, and just to say, Stalin looks to Peter the Great, you know, in the great crisis of the Nazi invasion, doesn't he? So he's very aware of these kind of parallels.
他非常赞成现代化之类的，名叫鲍里斯·谢列梅捷夫（Boris Sheremetyev）。所以他就是这个故事里的朱可夫。他正是如此。他就是那个将基本上调动俄国庞大的人力来击退这种所谓的不可战胜的瑞典杀戮机器的人。我的意思是，顺便说一句，斯大林在纳粹入侵的巨大危机中，把目光投向了彼得大帝，不是吗？所以他非常清楚这种相似之处。
So the Russians have been trying sort modernize in their army and drilling and kind of trying to conscript more people and whatnot. Meanwhile, why didn't Charles just strike into Russia right away? Now, some of his officers after the battle in Ava said, why don't we go on now to the Kremlin? Why don't we depose Peter? We could bring back Peter's sister, Sophia, to rule because she's still knocking around in a monastery. They can see all the downsides, you know, straight away. The weather, they don't have supplies.
因此，俄国人一直在努力让军队现代化，进行操练，并试图征召更多的人等等。与此同时，为什么查理不直接攻入俄国呢？现在，他在纳瓦战役后的一些军官说，我们为什么现在不去克里姆林宫呢？我们为什么不废黜彼得呢？我们可以带回彼得的姐姐索菲亚来统治，因为她还在修道院里晃悠。他们一眼就能看到所有的缺点，你知道的。天气，他们没有补给。
You know, they've all got dysentery, classic things that you have in wars in Eastern Europe. Charles says, no, no, no, we'll leave Peter for the time being. Actually, I want to really knock out Augustus the strong. Because it's personal there. It's personal. Let's knock out Saxony and Poland. So actually this is a really, really fateful decision.
你知道，他们都得了痢疾，这是东欧战争中的经典情况。查理说，不，不，不，我们暂时不管彼得。实际上，我真的想干掉强者奥古斯都（Augustus the strong）。因为这是个人的恩怨。这是私事。让我们干掉萨克森和波兰吧。所以这实际上是一个非常非常重大的决定。
He leaves Peter alone because he underestimates Peter and he says, let's concentrate on Augustus. And he thinks God has appointed me actually to punish Augustus. Augustus promised him that he would never go to war with him. Then he broke his word. Augustus has been hurling foxes around and killing badgers and stuff. And breeding an enormous number of children. 364 children. Yeah. Charles Dutton wouldn't approve of that, does he? I mean, I wonder whether there's a degree of, I mean, you say that he despises Peter as a war leader.
他放过彼得是因为他低估了彼得，他说，让我们集中精力对付奥古斯都。他认为上帝实际上指派他去惩罚奥古斯都。奥古斯都向他保证，他永远不会向他宣战。然后他食言了。奥古斯都一直在扔狐狸、杀獾之类的事。并孕育了大量的孩子。364个孩子。是的。查理·达顿不会赞成那个，对吧？我的意思是，我想知道是否有某种程度的，我的意思是，你说他作为战争领袖鄙视彼得。
Yeah. But I guess his contempt for Augustus is a kind of deeper, more moral one. Yeah, I think so. I think he regards Augustus as faithless, sort of shiftless. Force fleeting perjured. Exactly. So for various reasons, it takes a long time for this to get going. In 1702, he marches on Warsaw. He smashes Augustus's army, but Poland is a big place.
是的。但我想他对奥古斯都的蔑视是一种更深层次、更具道德感的蔑视。是的，我想是的。我想他认为奥古斯都背信弃义、游手好闲。随风倒、发誓背信。正是如此。因此，出于种种原因，事情花了很长时间才开始。1702年，他进军华沙。他粉碎了奥古斯都的军队，但波兰是一个很大的地方。
And basically he ends up chasing Augustus around Poland for what seems like months, if not years. And while all that's happening, that know, that's great for Peter because Peter can now work on this new army, which is conscripted from serfs and Ukrainian Cossacks. He can get his factories to start producing thousands of the latest flintlock muskets, to teach his men how to use the latest bayonets. They melt downloads of church bells for artillery. By the latest bayonets, they melt downloads of church bells for artillery. By the summer of 1702, the Russians have sorted themselves out and with Charles gone, they're
基本上，他最终在波兰追逐奥古斯都，时间长达数月甚至数年。而这一切发生的时候，你知道，这对彼得来说太棒了，因为彼得现在可以致力于这支新军队，它是从农奴和乌克兰哥萨克中征召的。他可以让他的工厂开始生产数千支最新的燧发滑膛枪，教他的士兵如何使用最新的刺刀。他们把大量的教堂钟声熔化用来做大炮。通过最新的刺刀，他们把大量的教堂钟声熔化用来做大炮。到1702年夏天，俄国人已经理清了头绪，随着查理的离去，他们
able to now move their troops into inland Livonia, Latvia, Estonia, and they're burning farms and villages and taking thousands of civilian prisoners. So Dominic, this is essentially the first time in Russian history that it is mobilizing the immensity of its resources, which are both kind of in terms of physical resources, but also population, and investing in this strategy of creating a wilderness so that potential invaders will not be able to penetrate into the heartlands of Russia itself. Yeah, that's a very good point, Tom. This is really the first moment in history that you have the Russian state
现在能够将部队转移到内陆的利沃尼亚、拉脱维亚、爱沙尼亚，他们正在烧毁农场和村庄，并抓捕数千名平民囚犯。所以多米尼克，这基本上是俄国历史上第一次调动其庞大的资源，这些资源既包括物质资源，也包括人口，并投资于创造一片荒野的战略，以便潜在的侵入者无法渗透到俄国本土的心脏地带。是的，说得好，汤姆。这确实是历史上第一次俄国国家
realizing that its strengths lie in its colossal reserves of manpower and mobilizing that and also the terrain and its size. Yeah, size, exactly, sheer size. Now I've said the Russians are rampaging through Livonia, the Cossacks often doing a lot of the rampaging and taking lots of prisoners. And I said that deliberately because there's one prisoner in particular that becomes incredibly important. There's a town in Latvia today called Eluxna, which at the time I think was called
意识到它的优势在于其庞大的人力资源并加以调动，还有地形和规模。是的，规模，没错，纯粹的规模。现在我说俄国人在利沃尼亚横冲直撞，哥萨克人经常进行大量的横冲直撞并抓捕大量囚犯。我是故意这么说的，因为有一个囚犯变得极其重要。拉脱维亚现在有一个小镇叫埃卢克斯纳（Eluxna），当时我想它被称为
Marienburg, kind of German name. And there the Russians captured, among their prisoners was a 17 year old girl who was probably called Marta Skowronska, or in Russian, Skavronskaya. So when they captured her, she was the girlfriend or mistress of a Swedish dragoon. And before that, she'd been a servant girl
马林堡（Marienburg），有点德国名字。在那里，俄国人俘虏了他们的囚犯，其中包括一个17岁的女孩，她可能叫玛尔塔·斯克沃恩斯卡娅（Marta Skowronska），或者用俄语说，斯卡夫龙斯卡娅（Skavronskaya）。所以当他们抓住她的时候，她是一个瑞典龙骑兵的女朋友或情妇。在此之前，她是一个女仆
for the local priest. And before that, she'd been a servant girl for the local priest. And before that, she had probably been born into a Catholic peasant family in the Grand Duchy of Lithuania. So that's the sort of Eastern half of this great Polish Commonwealth. Marta Skowronska can't read, she can't write, but she clearly has some kind of... Je ne sais quoi. Je ne sais quoi. Because Sieramitav, the commander, takes her on at some point as a servant girl. And then in 1703, she's taken up by another guy called Alexander Menshikov. Now we
为当地的牧师。在此之前，她曾是当地牧师的女仆。在此之前，她很可能出生在立陶宛大公国的一个天主教农民家庭。所以这就是这个伟大的波兰立陶宛联邦的大致东半部分。玛尔塔·斯克沃恩斯卡娅不会读书，也不会写字，但她显然有某种……难言之美。难言之美。因为司令官谢列梅捷夫在某个时候把她招为女仆。然后在1703年，她被另一个人亚历山大·缅什科夫（Alexander Menshikov）看中。现在我们
haven't mentioned Menshikov really yet, but he has a massive part to play in Peter's life. He'd possibly been a stable boy at the Royal estate. We don't really know. We definitely know that he had served in all those sort of war games that Peter liked to do. And he had quickly become Peter's great favourite and his closest friend. He is the sort of Charles Brandon figure of Peter's court. And he's replaced the Swiss guy who was Charles's great favorite before that and he's died and his name I can't remember. Franz LeFau.
还没有真正提到缅什科夫，但在彼得的生活中，他扮演了非常重要的角色。他可能曾是皇家庄园的马童。我们其实并不知道。我们非常确定的是，他曾服役于彼得喜欢进行的各种战争游戏。他很快成为了彼得的最爱和最亲密的朋友。他可以说是彼得宫廷中的查理·布兰登（Charles Brandon）式人物。他取代了那个瑞典人，后者曾是查理最喜欢的人，后来他死了，他的名字我记不得了。弗朗茨·勒福（Franz LeFau）。
Yeah. Exactly. Him. He has become his great drinking partner, his buddy, his carousing partner, and he's very greedy and ambitious, Menshikoff. He becomes an important commander for Peter, but he's kind of always festooning himself with kind of, he loves bling, he loves titles, all of that. A bit kind of a gering.
是的。完全正确。他成了他最好的酒友、哥们儿、狂欢的伙伴，而且他非常贪婪和野心勃勃，缅什科夫。他成了彼得手下的一名重要指挥官，但他总是喜欢用各种装饰来打扮自己，他喜欢珠光宝气，喜欢头衔，诸如此类。有点像戈林。
Yeah, I suppose. But he's not as fat. Yes, and not as evil, I think it's fair to say. But acquisitive. Yeah, very acquisitive. Anyway, Martha or Martha becomes his maidservant and probably his mistress. And while she is living with Menshikov, she converted to orthodoxy and she took the name Ekaterina, Catherine. And then he took her to Moscow and she met Peter.
是的，我猜吧。但他没那么胖。是的，我想说的是，也没那么邪恶。但很贪婪。是的，非常贪婪。无论如何，玛莎或玛塔成了他的女佣，很可能也是他的情妇。当她和缅什科夫住在一起时，她皈依了东正教，并取名叶卡捷琳娜，也就是凯瑟琳。然后他把她带到莫斯科，她遇到了彼得。
And Peter says, oh, what a tremendous woman, young girl. I'd like her as my mistress. And takes her up as his mistress. What it was that Catherine had appealed to Peter is I guess slightly unclear. His book for Robert K. Massey calls her a sturdy, healthy, appealing girl in the full bloom of youth. That's very much the way he likes to describe women.
彼得说，哦，多么了不起的女人，年轻的女孩。我想让她做我的情妇。并把她当作情妇带走了。凯瑟琳究竟吸引了彼得什么地方，我猜有点说不清楚。罗伯特·K·马西（Robert K. Massey）的书称她为“一个结实、健康、迷人的女孩，正值青春盛年”。这很符合他喜欢用来形容女人的方式。
A sturdy, handsome girl. A buxom wench. There's a lot of that. He does use the word buxom quite a lot. So she's not like tremendously glamorous or good looking, but there's something about her. Her sort of, dare I say her kind of rustic simplicity. I don't know. Well, he doesn't he call her mother? Yes. A bit like John Lennon with Yoko.
一个结实、漂亮的女孩。一个丰满的村姑。有很多这样的情况。他确实经常用“丰满”这个词。所以她并不是那种极其迷人或长得好看的人，但她身上有一种东西。她那种，我敢说，她那种乡村的纯朴。我不知道。嗯，他不是叫她妈妈吗？是的。有点像约翰·列侬和小野洋子。
So maybe there's a kind of mater, you know, he's missing mom. Possibly. She's, she's many years his junior, but she does kind of mother him. They become very close very quickly. She bears two sons, Peter and Paul in 1704 and 1705. They both die in infancy. And then in 1707, an extraordinary thing. Peter and Marta or Catherine, as she now calls herself, are married in secret.
所以也许有一种母亲般的（感觉），你知道的，他在想念妈妈。可能吧。她比他小很多岁，但她确实有点像母亲一样照顾他。他们很快变得非常亲密。她在1704年和1705年生下了两个儿子彼得和保罗。他们都在婴儿时期夭折了。然后在1707年，发生了一件非同寻常的事。彼得和玛莎，也就是现在自称的凯瑟琳，秘密结婚了。
They're married privately. And when you think that she is not even Russian, she's, she's an illiterate Lithuanian peasant girl who was subsequently converted to orthodoxy. And you think about all those bridal shows that they would have, you know, when he was growing up. I mean, this is a massive, massive departure from convention and must have been unbelievably shocking. But maybe again, for Peter, that's part of the fun of it. I for Peter that's part of the fun of it. I think that is probably part of the fun of it. Again, it's breaking a taboo. Actually the thing is everybody really liked her. So people would say she's so jolly, she's very generous, she loves a drink, she loves a joke, she would go on campaign.
他们私下结婚了。当你想到她甚至不是俄国人时，她是一个不识字的立陶宛农家女，后来皈依了东正教。再想想当他长大的时候，他们会举办的所有那些新娘选秀。我的意思是，这是一个巨大得多的对传统的背离，一定令人难以置信地感到震惊。但也许对彼得来说，这也是乐趣的一部分。我对于彼得来说，这也是乐趣的一部分。我想这可能也是乐趣的一部分。同样，这是在打破禁忌。事实上，大家都真的很喜欢她。所以人们会说她太快乐了，非常慷慨，她喜欢喝酒，喜欢开玩笑，她会去参加战役。
So very unlike Charles XII. He would have hated her. I mean they would not have got on at all. And whenever Peter has one of his fits or his tantrums or his rants, she will kind of calm him down, stroke his head and you know, all this sort of thing. Because he's presumably still having his twitching. He's twitching all the time. And actually the twitching becomes very bad when he's under pressure in the war, because the war's going badly for him for a long time.
所以这与查理十二世截然不同。他一定会讨厌她的。我的意思是，他们根本合不来。每当彼得发脾气、大发雷霆或长篇大论时，她都会安抚他，抚摸他的头，你知道的，诸如此类的事情。因为他大概还在抽搐。他一直在抽搐。事实上，当他在战争中承受压力时，抽搐变得非常严重，因为战争对他的情况很长一段时间都很糟糕。
So he's twitching like, I mean, he's twitching like anything. So you need someone to just kind of rub and calm him down. Exactly. Like a startled horse. Exactly. So that's one great addition to Peter's life. And the second is not a person, but it's a place. And this is massive, isn't it? It's huge. Historically, I mean, it couldn't be bigger. With Charles off in Poland, the Russian army were able to rampage a bit around Ingria,
所以他的抽搐就像，我的意思是，他抽搐得厉害。所以你需要有人来给他揉揉，让他平静下来。完全正确。就像一匹受惊的马。完全正确。所以这是彼得生活中的一大补充。第二个不是一个人，而是一个地方。这太巨大了，不是吗？太宏大了。历史上，我的意思是，不可能更大了。查理远在波兰，俄国军队得以在英格里亚（Ingria）四处横行，
this area. Sort of, what do you love? The Russians are rampaging around Ingria. Yeah, I love it. That is what this podcast is all about. So in 1702, they capture a Swedish fortress called Nurtborg, which is on Lake Ladoga. So people who listen to a Harold Hardrada series will remember Harold Hardrada passing this way centuries earlier.
这个地区。有点像，你喜欢什么？俄国人在英格里亚横冲直撞。是的，我喜欢。这就是这个播客的全部意义所在。所以在1702年，他们攻占了一个名为诺特堡（Nurtborg）的瑞典要塞，它位于拉多加湖畔。所以听过哈拉尔·哈德拉达（Harold Hardrada）系列节目的听众会记得哈拉尔·哈德拉达几个世纪前曾途径这里。
This- You do love a Northern war, don't you? I love a Northern war. I love a North Eastern war. This, I can't get enough of this. I guess if you spent so much of your professional career trapped in Harold Wilson's mind in 1973 or something. Bare killing in the frozen wastes of the North.
这个——你真的很喜欢北方战争，不是吗？我喜欢北方战争。我喜欢东北战争。这个，我怎么看都不嫌多。我想如果你把这么多的职业生涯都花在了1973年哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）的脑海里或类似的事情上。赤裸裸地在北方的冰天雪地中杀戮。
Yeah. Could not be a more refreshing change. In 1703, they take a second Swedish village, which is called Nynskans, which is just inland from the Baltic. And this now gives Peter the whole province of Ingria, which was one of his key war aims, he gives him access to the Baltic and it gives him the entire course of the river Neva. When he gets this, he thinks to himself, well, my goal, my real goal was to capture
是的。再也没有比这更令人耳目一新的改变了。1703年，他们攻占了第二个瑞典村庄，名叫尼恩斯坎斯（Nynskans），它就在波罗的海内陆不远处。这现在给了彼得整个英格里亚省，这是他的关键战争目标之一，这给了他通往波罗的海的通道，并给了他涅瓦河的全程。当他得到这个时，他心想，好吧，我的目标，我真正的目标是占领
Riga, which would be the ideal Baltic port, but the Swedes still have it. So now I'm just, since I've got the River Neva and access to the sea, I might as well just build my own version of Riga, a new port. It's an extraordinary thing to do because of course, this land might only be briefly occupied. I mean, the Swedes might try to get it back. a new port. It's an extraordinary thing to do because of course this land might only be briefly occupied. I mean, the Swedes might try to get it back. The war is still going and the surroundings are incredibly desolate. Well that doesn't naver in Finnish literally mean swamp.
里加（Riga），这将是理想的波罗的海港口，但瑞典人仍然控制着它。所以现在既然我有了涅瓦河和通往大海的通道，我不如就建我自己的里加版本，一个新港口。这是一件非同寻常的事情，因为当然，这片土地可能只会被短暂占领。我的意思是，瑞典人可能会试图夺回它。一个新港口。这是一件非同寻常的事情，因为当然，这片土地可能只会被短暂占领。我的意思是，瑞典人可能会试图夺回它。战争还在继续，周围的环境极其荒凉。嗯，芬兰语里的“涅瓦”不就是沼泽的意思吗？
Yeah, it's swamp land. It's swamp land. It's full of mosquitoes. It's incredibly boggy and miserable. The weather is terrible. It's windy. It's kind of foggy. It often gets frozen. He doesn't care. On the 16th of May, 1703, he says to his sort of sappers and workmen, get cracking on a fortress. We'll name it after St. Peter and St. Paul. And he stays nearby, you know, because he loves to, he loves a lathe, doesn't he? He loves a bit of carpentry. So he stays in a log cabin, which you can still see today, by the way, nearby. And the St. Peter and Paul fortress, which of course you can also see, but that at the time is built on an island, isn't it? So it's surrounded on all sides by the Neva.
是的，那是沼泽地。那是沼泽地。到处都是蚊子。极其泥泞，痛苦不堪。天气太糟糕了。风很大。有点起雾。经常结冰。他不在乎。1703年5月16日，他对他的工兵和工人们说，开始建造一座堡垒吧。我们将以圣彼得和圣保罗的名字命名它。他住在附近，你知道的，因为他喜欢，他喜欢车床，不是吗？他喜欢木工活。所以他住在一个圆木小屋里，顺便说一句，今天你仍然可以在附近看到它。圣彼得和圣保罗要塞，当然你也可以看到，但在当时它是建在一个岛上的，不是吗？所以它四面环绕着涅瓦河。
That kind of the Neva and marshes and stuff, bogs. So actually, that is one advantage of the inhospitability of the terrain is that, I mean, it's pretty defensible. Yeah, exactly. Well, as we'll see, he never loses it. So by the autumn of 1703, the first merchant ships are arriving from England and Holland. Peter says, if you keep coming, I'll give you massive tariff reductions. He's the very opposite, isn't he, of that chap in Washington, DC, because whereas President Trump likes a tariff, Peter the Great does not like a tariff. So by 1704,
涅瓦河、沼泽之类的，泥潭。所以实际上，地形的不适宜居住有一个好处，就是，我的意思是，它相当易守难攻。是的，完全正确。正如我们所看到的，他从未失去它。因此，到1703年秋天，第一批来自英国和荷兰的商船抵达了。彼得说，如果你继续来，我会给你大幅减税。他完全不是华盛顿特区那个家伙的对立面吗，因为特朗普总统喜欢关税，而彼得大帝不喜欢关税。所以在1704年，
he's building a shipyard and over time, he clearly begins to expand his ambitions. He thinks, well, rather than just a trading port, why don't we build a real city that will actually end up eclipsing? And so year after year, he's issuing these edicts saying, I want carpenters, I want masons, I want laborers, bring them north to work on this new city. We're going to build houses, we're going to build churches, we're even going to build palaces. And just to be clear about this, they are working in horrendous conditions and tens of thousands of them die. Well isn't the famous thing that is said about this city that it is built on bones?
他正在建造一个造船厂，随着时间的推移，他的野心显然开始扩大。他想，与其仅仅建造一个贸易港口，我们为什么不建造一个最终会超越它的真正城市呢？因此，年复一年，他发布这些法令，说我需要木匠，我需要石匠，我需要劳工，把他们带到北方来这座新城市工作。我们要建造房屋，我们要建造教堂，我们甚至要建造宫殿。为了把这一点说清楚，他们是在极其恶劣的条件下工作的，成千上万的人死去了。关于这座城市流传的著名说法难道不是它建立在骨头上吗？
Yes. That the foundations of this city are the corpses of all the labourers who have sunk into the bog. Exactly and died of hypothermia, of dysentery, of scurvy. They died of malaria even because of the mosquitoes. Everybody says this is literally the worst place on earth. This is a terrible, terrible place. But Peter is unrelenting and he even says to his sisters, to his courtiers, to the nobility of Moscow, come and live in my new city. Because he hates Moscow. He does hate Moscow. And one of his sisters said, this place is absolutely, this is unbelievably dreadful. And I quote, it will not endure
是的。这座城市的基石是所有沉入沼泽的劳工的尸体。正是如此，死于低体温症、痢疾、坏血病。他们甚至死于疟疾，因为蚊子。每个人都说这简直是地球上最糟糕的地方。这是一个可怕、可怕的地方。但彼得毫不留情，他甚至对他的姐妹们、对他的朝臣们、对莫斯科的贵族们说，来我的新城市住吧。因为他恨莫斯科。他确实恨莫斯科。他的一个姐妹说，这个地方绝对是，这简直令人难以置信地糟糕。我引述一下，“它不会持续到我们的时代之后，愿它沦为一片荒漠。”但当然它确实延续了下来，汤姆，因为这座城市的名字是？圣彼得堡。圣彼得堡。我能问你关于那个的问题吗？是的。所以这不是彼得格勒。不。圣彼得堡。是的。那为什么他，为什么它有一个德国名字？所以我认为有两个原因。第一，显然在波罗的海，通常地方都有德国名字，但也难道不是彼得通往西方的窗户吗？是的。
after our time, may it remain a desert. But of course it does endure Tom, because the name of this city? St. Petersburg. St. Petersburg. Can I just ask you about that? Yeah. So it's not Petrograd. No. St. Petersburg. Yeah. So why does he, why does it have the German name? So I think there are two reasons. One, obviously in the Baltic, generally places had German names, but also is it not perhaps Peter's window on the West? Yeah.
他的，他的，他的现代化野心。事实上，它从一开始就是。它向西看，而不是向东看，我认为，因为它是作为那些伟大城市的对等物构思的，你知道的，沿着波罗的海，那些汉萨同盟风格的城市，比如里加、塔林等等，所有这些在当时都有德国名字。俄国其他地方发生了什么？平心而论，彼得的手腕非常强硬，因为为了支付这一切以及他的战争和新城市，他正在征收各种各样的新税。有出生税、葬礼税、
His, his, his modernizing ambitions. The fact that it is always from the beginning. It's looking westwards, not eastwards, I think, because it's conceived as the equivalent of those great cities, you know, along the Baltic, those kind of Hanseatic style cities of Riga and Tallinn and whatnot, all of which at the time had German names. What's happening in the rest of Russia? It's fair to say that Peter's hand lies very heavy because to pay for all this and to pay for his war and his new city is levying all kinds of new taxes. There's a tax on births, on funerals,
小麦税、床税、帽子税。甚至还有胡须税，正如我们所知，已经有了胡须税。但他留着胡子。是的，可能交了税。他自己在纳税吗？我非常怀疑，但沙皇会纳税吗？他还征召了数量惊人的壮丁。30万士兵加入军队，3万人在南方的亚速（Azov）修建防御工事。
on wheat, on beds, on hats. There's even a tax on mustaches as we knew there was already a tax on beards. But he's got a mustache. Yeah, well probably pays it. Is he taxing himself? I would doubt very strongly, but the Tsar would pay tax. He's also conscripting absolutely unbelievable numbers of men. So 300,000 men into the army, 30,000 men to build fortifications at Azov down in the South.
你知道，数十万人被带来在圣彼得堡工作。有很多不满情绪。因此，在他的好友费多尔·罗曼诺夫斯基（Fedor Romanovsky）的领导下，他成立了一支新的秘密警察部队，以惩处，我引述一下，“言语或行动上的叛国罪”。那是那种——言语上的。言语上的。
You know, hundreds of thousands brought to work in St. Petersburg. There's a lot of discontent. So he has a new secret police under his mate Fedor Romanovsky to publish, and I quote, treason by word or deed. And that's sort of- By word. By word.
你知道，那是个稍微不祥的——所以那是口头上的言语，也是书面上的言语。是的，完全正确。还有叛乱。叛乱往往遵循一个既定的模式，人们会说，彼得太独裁了。他离经叛道。他太亲西方了。诸如此类。
You know, that's a slightly ominous- So that's the spoken word as well as the written word. Yes, exactly. And there are rebellions. And the rebellions tend to follow a set pattern that people will say, Peter is too authoritarian. He is unorthodox. He is too pro-German. All of this.
我的意思是，关于异端邪说和亲西方特征。我的意思是，他同时也在进行各种各样的改革，不是吗？因此，当他扮演暴君时，他也在扮演自由主义者。是的。好吧，我的意思是，你可以两者兼顾。他在很多方面都可以。我的意思是，我想我们可能会在最后一集中探讨这个问题。他在多大程度上是我们在18th世纪后期联想到的开明专制的鼻祖，这种开明专制可以说在拿破仑身上达到了顶峰？所以是一个既专制又改革的人。
I mean, on the unorthodoxy and the pro-Western character. I mean, he is also instituting all kinds of reforms at the same time, isn't he? So even as he is playing the despot, he's also playing the liberal. Yeah. Well, I mean, you can be both. He can in many ways. I mean, I think we'll get into this maybe in our final episode. How much is he a progenitor of the enlightened despotism that we associate with the later 18th century that arguably reaches its culmination in Napoleon? So somebody who's simultaneously authoritarian and reforming.
例如，他刚刚结婚。他摆脱了所有这些，你知道的，父亲把鞭子交给新郎之类的东西。他基本上是在说，人们可以嫁给他们喜欢的人。正是如此。他还建立新的学校、报纸、印刷厂等等。在某些方面你会说，嗯，那将鼓励思想自由和言语自由等等。所以是一个善良的人。但很强硬，我认为这样说很公平。是的，所以发生了这些叛乱。所以读这些辩护词很有趣。所以在1705年的阿斯特拉罕（Astrakhan），叛军说，我们站出来，并且
For instance, he's just got married. He's got rid of all that, you know, the stuff of the father handing the whip over to the bridegroom and all that kind of stuff. And essentially he's saying that people can marry whoever they like. Exactly. And he's set up new schools, newspapers, printers, and so on. In some ways you would say, well, that will encourage freedom of thought and freedom of speech and so on. So a kindly man. But robust, I think it's fair to say. Yeah, so there were these rebellions. So it's entertaining to read the justification. So in Astrakhan 1705, the rebels say, we're standing up, and
我引述一下，“为了基督教信仰，反对剃须、德国服饰和烟草，以及因为我们和我们的妻子及孩子没有穿着俄罗斯传统服装被允许进入上帝的教堂。”所以这些我们讨论过的其他琐事，胡须和服装等等，对人们来说非常重要。我的意思是，它们象征着更深层次的东西，也就是俄国人所认为的俄国独特性，以及它真正作为第三罗马、高举真信仰蜡烛的地位。1707年哥萨克人在顿河（River Don）发动的一起叛乱，是因为有传言称他要彻底取缔胡须。我们不能对邪恶之人、诸侯、暴利者和德国人的罪行保持沉默。我们不能原谅他们用他们的标志和狡猾的把戏把我们从真正的基督教信仰中引开。
I quote, for the Christian faith and against shaving and German dress and tobacco, and because we and our wives and children were not admitted into God's church in the old Russian dress. So these things that we've talked about as other trivialities, beards and clothing and so on, they are very important to people. I mean, they symbolize something deeper, which is Russia's, what they see is Russia's distinctiveness and it's, and it's really, and it's placed as the third Rome, as the carrying the candle of the true faith. A rebellion by Cossacks in 1707 on the River Dawn provoked because of rumours that he was going to outlaw beards completely. We cannot be silent on the account of the evil deeds of wicked men and princes and profit makers and Germans. We cannot forgive them for diverting us from the true Christian faith with their signs and cunning tricks.
因此，从这个意义上说，圣彼得堡有一个德国名字，这必然使它看起来像他们所恨的一切的绝对化身。我想是的。而且我认为总是有人，俄国一直都有人，可能今天没那么多了，但在很长一段时间里，俄国有人认为这是走错了路。你知道，这是我们误入歧途的象征，是我们失去斯拉夫传统和东正教根源的地方。因此，从这一点开始，莫斯科和圣彼得堡是俄国境内的两个极点。正是如此。那是彼得，但查理怎么了？查理在忙什么？所以我们离开查理时，他正前往波兰对付强者奥古斯都，对奥古斯都赢得了无数场战役。
And so in that sense, the fact that St. Petersburg has a German name must make it seem like the absolute embodiment of everything that they hate. I think so. And I think there are always people, there have always been people in Russia, probably not so much today, but for a long time there were people in Russia who thought this was the wrong turn. You know, this is a symbol of where we went wrong, where we lost our Slavic traditions and our kind of Orthodox roots. And so Moscow and St Petersburg from this point on are the twin poles within Russia. Exactly. So that's Peter, but what's happened to Charles? What's Charles been up to? So we left Charles heading into Poland to deal with Augustus the Strong, winning loads of battles against Augustus.
他占领了克拉科夫（Krakow），这个波兰古老的皇家首都，但奥古斯都不断地像融化一样溜走。随着时间的推移，从波罗的海传来了令人担忧的报告。因此查理听说彼得已经重整旗鼓，他占领了这些城镇，他建立了圣彼得堡，他最终确实占领了纳尔瓦。他从瑞典收到了报告，查理。人们挨饿，他们疲惫不堪，他们失去了来自利沃尼亚的粮食供应，他们对战争感到精疲力竭。但查理就是不肯停下。
He'd captured Krakow, the kind of ancient royal capital of Poland, but Augustus keeps kind of melting away. And as time goes on, there are sort of worrying reports coming in from the Baltic. So Charles hears that Peter has got his act back together, that he has captured these towns, that he's founded St Petersburg, that he does end up capturing Narva in the long run. He gets reports from Sweden, Charles. People are hungry, they're tired, they've lost the grain supply from Livonia, they're becoming exhausted of the war. But Charles just will not stop.
我的意思是，他赢得的战役远远多于输掉的。而且，你知道的，他有效地击退了任何这个联盟，但他不会妥协。他对他的朝臣说，奥古斯都对我说谎了，我必须惩罚他。即使我留在这里，也就是在波兰呆上50年，在奥古斯都被废黜之前，我绝不离开这个国家。最终在1704年，他胁迫波兰议会同样废黜了奥古斯都。他让他们在华沙郊外开会，他在场地四周部署了瑞典滑膛枪手，他们投票将奥古斯都赶下台，因为记住波兰立陶宛
I mean, he's won far more battles than he's lost. And, you know, he's seen off any this coalition effectively, but he will not come to terms. He says to his courtiers, Augustus broke his word to me and I have to punish him. Even if I should remain here, that's in Poland for 50 years, I will not leave this country until Augustus is dethroned. And eventually in 1704, he bullies the Polish parliament the same into deposing Augustus. He gets them to meet outside Warsaw, he rings the field with Swedish musketeers, they vote Augustus out, because remember Polish, the Thuain
联邦是一个选举君主国，他们扶植了一个名叫斯坦尼斯瓦夫·莱什琴斯基（Stanislaw Leszczynski）的瑞典傀儡。印象深刻。你很享受。我不得不提到他的名字，但我认为我应该这样做，仅仅为了……因为那是一个有很多Z和C的名字。是的。这就是我要说的。太棒了。老实说，我整个周末都没有练习。这才是正确的方式。现在，奥古斯都，他并没有放弃。我的意思是，他真的是一个伟大的人物，他喜欢扔狐狸，还有——弯曲马蹄铁之类的事情。是的，6000个孩子。他乔装打扮逃到了匈牙利。他在现在属于白俄罗斯的地方与俄国人会合。他溜过了查理，回到了波兰，大概是希望回到萨克森，因为他当然还是萨克森国王。所以到
and Commonwealth is an elective monarchy and they install a Swedish puppet who's called Stanislaw Leszczynski. So impressed. You enjoyed that. I didn't have to mention his name, but I thought I'd do it just to... Because that is a name with a lot of Zs and Cs. Yeah. That's all I'll say. Love it. I wasn't practicing all weekend, honestly. That's the right way. Now, Augustus, he doesn't give up. I mean, he's a great character really with his fox tossing and his- Bending horseshoes and things. Yeah, 6,000 children. He escapes into Hungary in disguise. He rendezvous with the Russians in what's now Belarus. He slips past Charles and gets back into Poland, presumably hoping to head back towards Saxony because of course he's still King of Saxony. So by
1706年，我的意思是，这真的变成了一场失控的疯狂风险游戏。是的，去入侵堪察加。是的，查理心想，好吧，我也要入侵萨克森了。所以他入侵了萨克森，他这里的逻辑是，这是奥古斯都的核心领土萨克森。这是彻底将他清除出战争的唯一途径。再次，这进展得非常顺利。萨克森人彻底精疲力竭了，萨克森人民听到瑞典人要来的消息时，还记得三十年战争，他们就想，哦不，这是可能发生的最糟糕的事情。因此在几周内，查理和瑞典人就占领了莱比锡和德累斯顿。
1706, I mean, this really is turning into like a game of a mad game of risk that's got completely out of hand. Yeah, off to invade Kamchatka. Yeah, Charles thinks, well, I'm just going to invade Saxony as well now. So he invades Saxony and his logic here is this is Augustus' heartland Saxony. This is the only way to knock him definitively out of the war. And again, it goes brilliantly. The Saxons are absolutely knackered to the people of Saxony when they hear the Swedes are coming, remember the 30 years war and they're just like, oh no, this is the worst thing that could possibly happen. So within weeks, Charles and the Swedes have occupied Leipzig and Dresden.
我的意思是，老实说，你会想他为什么不早点这么做。是的，在波兰瞎折腾之后。走进树林和沼泽之类的东西。我想，但我的意思是，这太疯狂了，不是吗？瑞典人占领了莱比锡和德累斯顿。我的意思是，我们提到这一点好像什么都不是一样，但此时他们距离瑞典有数百英里远。但他们有前科，我说过，古斯塔夫·阿道夫（Gustavus Adolphus）。
I mean, you wonder why he didn't do it before, to be honest. Yeah, after faffing around in Poland. Going into woods and bogs and things. I suppose, but I mean, it is a mad thing, isn't it? The Swedes occupying Leipzig and Dresden. I mean, we're sort of mentioning that as though it's nothing, but they're hundreds of miles away from Sweden at this point. But they've got a track record, I said, Gustavus Adolphus.
他们喜欢这样。在维滕贝格。此后瑞典人心理的转变，我的意思是，我猜是因为发生的事情太痛苦了。这有点像，我想不出历史上有多少个例子，一个民族曾经如此不可思议的好战、残暴，然后变成了格雷塔·通贝里（Greta Thunberg）。无论如何。因此，萨克森现在匍匐在他脚下，在经历了大量的折腾，军事和外交上的折腾，这是你不需要深入了解的之后，奥古斯都终于投降了。他正式退位波兰国王，并切断了与俄国的同盟。
They love it. In Wittenberg. The transformation of the Swedish psyche after this, I mean, I guess it's because it's so traumatic what happens. It's kind of, I can't think of many equivalents in history of a people who have been just so unbelievably ruthless warlike and then turn into Greta Thunberg. Well, anyway. So Saxony is now a prostrate before him and after a lot of faffing around, military and diplomatic faffing around, which you don't need to go into, Augustus finally surrenders. He abdicates as King of Poland formally and he breaks his alliance with Russia.
更糟糕的是，奥古斯都非常背信弃义，因为更糟糕的是，这次投降的条件之一是他必须交出这个人，约翰·赖inhard·冯·帕特尔（Johann Reinhard von Patkel）。哦，波罗的海男爵。波罗的海男爵，他策划了这一切。那是查理坚持的，不是吗？查理坚持这一点。他非常记仇。在保证不这样做之后，奥古斯都把他关起来，不给吃喝
And what is worse, I mean Augustus is very faithless because what is worse, one of the conditions for this surrender is he has to hand over this guy, Johann Reinhard von Patkel. Oh, the Baltic Baron. Baltic Baron who'd put this whole thing together. And that's Charles insisting on that, isn't it? Charles insists on that. He's very vengeful. After promising that he wouldn't, Augustus has him locked up without food and water for
五天。我猜很多人有一种成见，认为俄国人极其冷酷无情，但实际上在这方面，彼得相当多情。他说，我认为你不应该把这个帕特尔家伙交出去。我的意思是，这表现真的很差。但这却是一个曾把斯特列利齐（Streltsy）折磨至死的人。那是真的。我的意思是，我不能接受这种……但在这一点上，他是仁慈的。他是个心地善良的人。他不是。
five days. I guess a lot of people have a stereotype that the Russians are unbelievably ruthless, but actually in this, Peter is quite sentimental. He says, I don't think you should give this guy pack all over. I mean, that's really bad form. But this is a guy who'd been mounting his, you know, the Streltsy to death. That's true. I mean, I'm not having this kind of... But in this respect, he's kindly. He's a kindly man. He's not.
但在这一点上，彼得说，我认为我们不应该把帕特尔交出去。我认为这真的很糟糕。奥古斯都具体保证了，我绝不那样做。然后他做的第一件事就是把他交出去。所以不仅是俄国人喜欢虐待。瑞典人让一个刽子手用大锤将帕特尔的车轮刑处决，用大锤砸了他15次，打断了他所有的四肢。哦天哪..帕特尔
But in this respect, Peter says, I don't think we should hand Pat Cole over. I think that's really bad. And Augustus specifically promises, I'll never do that. And then literally the next thing he does is to hand him over. So it's not just the Russians who love a bit of torture. The Swedes had Pat Cole broken on the wheel by an executioner with a sledgehammer who hit him 15 times with the sledgehammer to break all his limbs. Oh God.. Pat Cole
一直在尖叫和喊叫，砍下我的头，砍下我的头，因为他想让他们结束他的痛苦。但后来刽子手的斧子用得不是很好。他更擅长用大锤。他确实是个大锤手。他用乡村斧子砍了四次，帕特尔的头才掉下来。好吧，我的意思是，其中的道德教训是不要背叛你的领主，我猜。是的，不，别这么做。所以此时我们正处于17年，我们正在进入1707年，老实说，对查理来说一切都进行得太棒了。我知道有圣
was screaming and shouting, take off my head, take off my head, because he wanted them to put him out of his agony. But then the executioner was not very good with the axe. He was better with the sledgehammer. He was a sledgehammer man really. And it took him four goes with a country axe before Pat Cole's head was off. Well, I mean, the moral of that is don't betray your overlord, I guess. Yeah, no, don't. So at this point we're in 17, we're entering 1707 and let's be honest, everything has gone brilliantly really for Charles. I know there's St.
彼得堡。他失去了那个，但除此之外，丹麦人被击败了。波兰和萨克森基本上是他的傀儡。他的手下崇拜他。他们认为他战无不胜。在整个欧洲，查理十二世被视为这个时代的明星、超级巨星。他冒险的故事有点像亚历山大大帝、汉尼拔或其他人，传遍了整个欧洲。他不穿盔甲。他不戴帽子。人们对此感到惊讶
Petersburg. He's lost that, but apart from that, Danes are knocked out. Poland and Saxony are basically his puppets. His men adore him. They think he's invincible. All across Europe, Charles XII is seen as the celebrity, the superstar of the age. And tales of his adventures rather like with Alexander the Great or Hannibal or whoever, spreads you know all over Europe. He doesn't wear armour. He won't wear a hat. People are amazed
他在战役期间不戴帽子。下雪时他不穿保暖的衣服。他以面包和水为食。他和手下睡在木板床上。他每天晚上读圣经，并让手下跪下祈祷。军队在行军时，他们必须全部跪下祈祷。在雪地里。是的。一天两次。
by this. He won't wear a hat while he's on campaign. He doesn't wear a, you know, warm clothes when it's snowing. He dines on bread and water. He sleeps on bed boards with his men. He reads every night from the Bible and he makes his men kneel to pray. The troop, the army while they're marching, they have to all kneel and pray. In the snow. Yeah. Twice a day.
诸如此类的事情。他基本上就是打了激素的奥利弗·克伦威尔（Oliver Cromwell），来自欧洲各地。人们派遣大使来拉拢他。因此路易十四（Louis the 14th）派遣了一位大使，并说，听着，你知道的，为什么我们，法国人和瑞典人联手，我们瓜分德国，瓜分欧洲？这难道不棒吗？为了说清楚，我的意思是，法国有2000万人口，瑞典有150万。是的，随便吧。正是如此。他们把我们当平等对待。
All of this kind of thing. He's like Oliver Cromwell on steroids basically from all over Europe. People send ambassadors to basically get him on side. So Louis the 14th sends an ambassador and says, look, you know, why don't we, the French and the Swedes team up, we'll divide Germany between us, divide Europe between us. Wouldn't this be brilliant? Just to be clear, I mean, France has 20 million people, Sweden has 1.5 million. Yeah, whatever it is. Exactly. And they're treating us equals.
正是如此。然后这个时代的另一个伟人，马尔伯勒公爵（Duke of Marlborough），约翰·丘吉尔（John Churchill），英国军队的伟大英雄，他亲自前往查理在萨克森阿尔特朗斯特（Altronstedt）的总部，带着安妮女王（Queen Anne）的一封信，基本上是说，请不要和法国人上床。马尔伯勒认为查理十二世太棒了。我的意思是，我们认为是这个时代伟大指挥官的马尔伯勒，对查理十二世赞不绝口。但查理十二世认为马尔伯勒穿得太多，对吧？他确实觉得，有点矫揉造作。而且他的语言太华丽了。
Exactly. And then the other great man of the age, the Duke of Marlborough, John Churchill, the great hero of English arms, he went personally to Charles' headquarters in a place called Altronstedt in Saxony with a letter from Queen Anne to basically say, please don't get into bed with the French. Marlborough thinks Charles XII is amazing. I mean, Marlborough, who we think of as the great commander of the age, he can't get enough of Charles XII. But Charles XII thinks Marlborough is overdressed, doesn't he? He does, a bit foppish. And his language is flowery.
真的吗？他的语言太华丽了。天哪。但瑞典人仍然对所有人这样说，不是吗？他确实有点矫揉造作。而且他的语言太华丽了。真的吗？他的语言太华丽了。天哪。但瑞典人仍然对所有人这样说，对吧？我的意思是，你不会看到查理十二世为自己建造一座像布伦海姆宫（Blenheim）那样宏伟的宫殿，对吧？不，你不会。你绝对不会。所以我认为即使在这一刻，1707年，甚至彼得也认为，你知道的，
Really? His language is too flowery. God. But the Swedes still say that about everybody, don't he? He does a bit foppish. And his language is flowery. Really? His language is too flowery. God. But the Swedes still say that about everybody, don't they? I mean, you wouldn't have Charles XII building himself an enormous palace like Blenheim, would you? No, you wouldn't. You absolutely would not. So I think even at this point, 1707, even Peter thinks, you know,
我可能永远也打不过这家伙。这家伙真的就是亚历山大大帝。再打下去也没有意义了。实际上彼得开始寻找调停人。他首先去了法国，他说，如果你能为我达成和平协议，我实际上会帮助你对抗英国。什么？我以为他爱英国。我知道。太令人震惊了。
I'll probably never beat this guy. Like this guy really is Alexander the Great. There's no point in fighting on. And actually Peter starts looking around for someone to mediate. He went to the French first and he said, if you will sort out a peace deal for me, I'll actually help you against the English. What? I thought he loved the English. I know. Shocking.
这没有表现出对英国允许他在花园里推独轮车比赛的太多感激。但听好了。然后他派他的大使去见马尔伯勒公爵。他说，看，如果你能让安妮女王向瑞典人进行调停，我会把马尔伯勒送给你。你可以挑选基辅、弗拉基米尔和西伯利亚的任何一个亲王国。我每年给你5万达克特（ducats）。我会给你俄国最高的荣誉，圣安德鲁勋章。我引述一下，“一颗欧洲最大的红宝石”。哇。
That's not showing much gratitude for the English allowing him to have wheelbarrow races across gardens. But get this. Then he sends his ambassador to go and see the Duke of Marlborough. And he says, look, if you can get Queen Anne to mediate with the Swedes, I will give you Marlborough. You can have your pick of the principalities of Kiev, Vladimir and Siberia. I'll give you 50,000 ducats a year. I'll give you the highest Russian honor, the order of St. Andrew. And I quote, a ruby as large as any in Europe. Wow.
所以马尔伯勒公爵可以成为基辅的领主。是的。我的意思是，那将是一个外交解决方案，不是吗？那将是惊人的。我想知道是否有人想过这一点。如果发生了那将是一件了不起的事情，但它没有发生，因为他们永远不会达成休战，因为彼得不会放弃圣彼得堡。他在上面投入了太多，不仅仅是情感上，而且查理永远不会让步圣彼得堡。但同时查理有一块。查理只是认为，
So the Duke of Marlborough could be the overlord of Keeve. Yeah. I mean, that would be a diplomatic solution, wouldn't it? That would be amazing. I wonder if anyone thought of that. It would have been amazing thing if it had happened, but it doesn't happen because they will never reach a truce because Peter will not give up St. Petersburg. He's invested so much in it, not just emotionally, and Charles will never concede St. Petersburg. But also Charles has one piece. Charles just thinks,
因此马尔博罗公爵可以成为基辅的领主。是的。我的意思是，那将是一个外交解决方案，不是吗？那将是惊人的。我想知道是否有人想到过这一点。如果真的发生了，那将是一件了不起的事情，但它并没有发生，因为他们永远不会达成休战协议，因为彼得不会放弃圣彼得堡。他在其中投入了太多，不仅仅是情感上的，而且查理永远不会让步圣彼得堡。但查理也有一张王牌。查理只是认为，
I have the best army in Europe. I never lose. Why would I give up anything in the Baltic? Why would I make the slightest concession? Because when I turn finally to deal with the Russians, make the slightest concession because when I turn finally to deal with the Russians, I will wipe the floor with them. And so as he's sitting there in Saxony, Charles, in the summer of 1707, he has a much better idea than a deal with the Duke of Marlborough. His idea is, I lead my invincible army east through Poland, into Russia, into Moscow itself, and I will sit in the Kremlin and I will dictate the terms myself. So I've got two questions on that strategy. The first is, is there no sense that he's
我有欧洲最强大的军队。我从不战败。我为什么要放弃波罗的海的任何东西？我为什么要做出哪怕一丝一毫的让步？因为当我最终转身去对付俄国人时，做出哪怕一丝一毫的让步，因为当我最终转身去对付俄国人时，我会把他们彻底消灭。因此，当查理在1707年夏天坐在萨克森时，他有一个比与马尔伯勒公爵达成交易好得多的主意。他的想法是，我率领我战无不胜的军队向东穿过波兰，进入俄国，直抵莫斯科本身，我将坐在克里姆林宫里亲自口授条约条款。所以我有关于这个战略的两个问题。第一个是，难道他没有意识到他
learnt his lesson from all this kind of herring around Poland and finding it impossible to pin down his enemy there? And also why doesn't he just march on St. Petersburg? Because I think he thinks that if he takes St. Petersburg, so what, you know, Peter will still be, he wants to crush Peter. He wants to decapitate the Russian state. He wants a war of destruction. Total war. Total war, I think.
从在波兰周围四处搜寻却发现无法锁定那里的敌人这种经历中吸取教训吗？而且他为什么不直接进军圣彼得堡？因为我认为他觉得如果他占领了圣彼得堡，那又怎样，你知道，彼得依然会存在，他想要摧毁彼得。他想要斩首俄罗斯国家。他想要一场毁灭性的战争。全面战争。我想，这是一场全面战争。
Exactly. I think he's at this point slightly believing his own publicity. He wants a campaign like an Alexander style. He wants to go into Persepolis. Well, again, again, we are going to be doing a series on Hannibal after this, the echoes of Hannibal that Dr. Johnson picked up on. I mean, he, I guess, you know, Hannibal attacks Rome, the absolute heart of the enemy. And I suppose that's what Peter is doing. But I mean, it's kind of a massive undertaking, isn't it? But I guess, I guess that Charles doesn't have the example of himself or Napoleon before him.
没错。我认为他在这个时候有点相信了自己的宣传。他想要一场亚历山大风格的战役。他想进入波斯波利斯。嗯，再说一次，在这之后我们将制作一个关于汉尼拔的系列节目，约翰逊博士注意到了汉尼拔的回响。我的意思是，他，我猜，你知道，汉尼拔进攻罗马，那是敌人的绝对核心。我想这就是彼得正在做的事情。但我的意思是，这是一个巨大的宏伟工程，不是吗？不过我想，查理没有他自己或他身后的拿破仑的前车之鉴。
Right. What he does have is the example of the Poles who occupied Moscow. Of course. Um, a hundred years earlier. So it's been done at this point. It is totally doable. It's been done. Now there are people who say, really?
对。他确实有占领过莫斯科的波兰人的前车之鉴。当然。嗯，早了一百年。所以在这一点上这是曾经发生过的。这完全是可行的。这已经做过了。现在有些人说，真的吗？
So his Polish puppet, there's been an opportunity to show off again. His name, of course, Tom is Stanisław Fleszczyński. His Polish puppet says, really? The Kremlin, are you sure? And Charles says explicitly, listen, you can't live next door to this unjust czar who begins a war without any good cause. The power of Muscovy must be broken and destroyed. In other words, kill the snake. And he draws up this plan. He will march with majority of the Swedish force through Poland, through the Grand Duchy of Lithuania, and he will be drawing off Russian troops from the Baltic that way. That will allow a second Swedish advance to come south from Riga with supplies from Sweden.
所以他的波兰傀儡，又有一个展现才华的机会了。他的名字，汤姆，当然是斯坦尼斯瓦夫·莱什钦斯基。他的波兰傀儡说，真的吗？克里姆林宫，你确定吗？查理明确表示，听着，你不能和一个无缘无故发动战争的无道沙皇毗邻而居。莫斯科的权力必须被粉碎和摧毁。换句话说，斩草除根。他拟定了这个计划。他将率领大部分瑞典军队穿过波兰，穿过立陶宛大公国，他将以此从波罗的海抽调俄国军队。这将允许第二支瑞典军队带着来自瑞典的补给从里加向南推进。
These two armies will meet in Western Russia before the final advance on Moscow. So all summer he makes his preparations, recruits tens of thousands of extra volunteers from the Protestants of Saxony and Silesia. He has Swedish reinforcements brought to Poland. They have the latest swords, they have blue and yellow Swedish coloured uniforms, they even have new Bibles and hymn books because of course there's a religious dimension to this. Very new model army, isn't it? Very new model army. The spirit could not be higher. And so on the evening of the 26th of August 1707, there's a big prayer service, a final prayer service for Charles' troops, and the next morning he rides out of Ulltrundstedt, his Saxon headquarters, at the head of his army.
这两支军队将在向莫斯科最后进军之前在俄罗斯西部会师。因此整个夏天他都在做准备，从萨克森和西里西亚的新教徒中招募了数万名额外的志愿者。他把瑞典增援部队带到了波兰。他们拥有最新式的长剑，穿着蓝黄相间的瑞典军服，他们甚至还有新的圣经和赞美诗，因为这其中当然有宗教维度的考量。这是一支非常新模范的军队，不是吗？非常新模范的军队。士气高涨到了极点。因此，在1707年8月26日的傍晚，举行了一场盛大的祈祷仪式，这是为查理的部队举行的最后一场祈祷仪式，第二天早晨他骑马离开萨克森总部乌尔特伦施泰特，率领他的军队出发了。
He's commanding the largest army ever commanded by a Swedish king. It is the most lethal military machine in Europe, victory after victory, and they are bound for Moscow and what will surely be a triumph that will resound down the ages. Well, Dominic, what could possibly go wrong? Members of the Rest is History Club can find out how Charles XII's invasion of Russia goes right now by listening to the next episode in this epic series on the life of Peter the Great. If you're not a member and would like to do that, then of course, you know what you have to do.
他统帅着由瑞典国王指挥过的最大规模军队。这是欧洲最具杀伤力的军事机器，一场又一场的胜利，他们正开往莫斯科，等待他们的必将是流芳百世的伟大胜利。好了，多米尼克，还有什么会出岔子呢？“历史的其余部分”俱乐部成员现在就可以通过收听关于彼得大帝生平这一史诗系列节目的下一集，来了解查理十二世入侵俄国的结局。如果你还不是会员并且想这么做，那么当然，你知道你该怎么做。
You can sign up at therestishistory.com. If not, we'll be back on Thursday with the next installment of the Great Northern War. Goodbye. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在therestishistory.com注册。如果没有，我们将在周四带着《大北方战争》的下一集回归。再见。再见。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。